day two of the semi-finals in clubs
chess champions showdown the top four
players in the United States were back
in action to decide who moved on and who
would go home Fabiano Caruana overcame
linear to Vegas with a dominating
performance while wesayso stormed back
with three stunning victories against
Hikaru Nakamura and held on at the end
to book his ticket into the finals two
Olympic teammates go toe-to-toe in our
hunt for the trophy the first day of the
exciting books chess finals coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
Colette chess we have entered the finals
I'm Jennifer jihadi and I'm here again
with Yasser sever one and Morris Ashley
to bring to you this action-packed day
of chess not quite like what you're used
to seeing yes hello hello Jennifer hello
Maurice hello everyone and welcome to
our finals of clutch chess and what semi
finals
we enjoyed oh my goodness as we saw
fabulous Fabian
some of the best chess I've ever
witnessed that young man playing it was
the pleasure and coming back and day to
Wesley so was just regal it was
fantastic and I'm looking forward to a
great finals I love your format Maurice
well right now which everybody's format
the fact that they played it's such
incredible Elan aggressiveness you
looked at how Fabi played it look like
an alien inhabited his body he played
with such amazing just passion to want
to destroy his opponent which is what he
absolutely did 15-3 what kind of score
is that and Wesley so of course with the
comeback after a disaster in Game five
not winning a game were your three pawns
up in an endgame that's can't the
bounce-back
and especially then losing the next
clutch game but he showed his spirit
with three wins in a row to start the
second day off and he never looked back
and here's what we got here this is the
bracket as you can see Wesley so that
narrow margin of victory against the
rapid blitz bullet legend he carved
who's not outta here he is gone from the
competition as is when you're Dominguez
no that match on the other hand not as
close look at that big fat 18 points at
Fabiano Carolina scored which is going
to put him in this critical finals match
against Wesley so as we will be crowning
our first ever clutch Chess Champion and
here's how the format works for those of
you who didn't see the semis it is going
to work the same way so we're gonna have
six teams a day that's six games today
in six games tomorrow on Friday start
out with four regular rapid games worth
one point each using our scoring system
and then we go to our final two games of
the day which is going to be in clutch
game fashion we're two points each as
yesterday will all be played a game 10
with a five-second increment per move
and I'm just itching to see how this is
gonna get going but we do have a
grandmaster Maurice Ashley to give us a
little bit of insight into everyone that
was invited to clutch chess
those who were vanquished and those who
still remain well Indy we're talking
about four of America's stars the top
four at the moment as a matter of fact
but somebody had to win and somebody had
to lose that's the nature of the format
and we see first of all linear Dominguez
he played against Fabiano Caruana
and what can he say he's trying to
figure out what train ran over him as he
ended up scoring just the three points
and taking home the $10,000 no clutch
money for him but he will learn his
lesson and come back in future events
and we had akaru
Nakamura many people would have booked
him as the favorite at least to make the
finals and not win the whole thing
but he was not able to do so he did win
much Game six and took home two grand
for his efforts extra on top of the
tents of 12,000 in total but those two
now have left building talk about people
staying in the building
fabulous money on the Caruana it looks
like he's trying to on the bed house 15
to 3 was his score against linear
Dominguez playing absolutely brilliant
chess Rock'em Sock'em Fabian just looks
incredible right now and not only that
he said you know what I'm taking all the
clutch money as well the whole ten grand
winning game twelve of course winning
Game six as well but then all the bonus
money ended up rolling over and game
twelve he said hey that's it I got it
all for myself so he's got ten grand
extra without even playing any more
moves so he's certainly quite happy but
somebody who wants to be more happy than
he has of course is Wesley so who did he
get out at the end after a bad first day
of the sour taste in his mouth but then
he came back in fine form managed to
draw that last game that was very
important to keep that edge one Vitus
limits of margins but hey they don't get
the prize for second place so he's happy
to be on now he will play against Bobby
it should be absolutely a great match
and he starts it off with white so we'll
see if he can throw the gauntlet down
and try to take down this monster we
should point out by the way Fabi is
number two in the world so it's not
gonna be easy not at all and Jennifer
what are they playing for so much at
stake as here we've got seventy thousand
dollars up for grabs and that includes
by the way 30k for first place you walk
away with twenty thousand dollars for a
second and there's also the clutch money
and the crazy thing is because of the
earlier games yesterday there's so much
money at stake tomorrow in the final two
clutch games seven thousand dollars per
game and that could be even more if
today's buzz games are drawn and what
that means is that theoretically Fabiano
could lose the match and still walk away
with a lot more money how ironic that
would be and now as and now as the match
is about to get underway let's let's say
quickly who's your favorite in the
competition Jen I gotta suffer from
recency bias and to go with Wesley so
because that was some vintage what was
it 2016 Wesley so I mean just sparkling
it almost felt like he merged the best
qualities of human with machine like he
was just playing beautiful moves and I
also couldn't help but be influenced by
the fact that he said yet 14 hours of
sleep I mean the cognitive impact of all
of that sleep how does he do it good
rest good rest and Maurice who's your
pick to be here well Jen's going with
combination man versus machine
I'm going with the Terminator Fabiana I
mean the way he played he just looked
like he said listen I'll be back and I'm
taking absolutely no prisoners
absolutely great play yes he did have
some difficult positions yesterday
against linear but I've seen this story
before a player who is in such great
form yeah you're gonna get bad positions
you can't get all great positions on the
opening but you win the good ones you
win the even ones and you win the bad
ones as well so I'm thinking Fabi should
be able to pull this one off wow that
means I could to play tiebreaker this is
pretty pretty difficult actually because
you're both making really compelling
cases but I'm gonna have to come down
with Jennifer as well a recency unusual
story as well three wins in a row and
what wins they were against Hikaru oh my
goodness yeah I I'm predicting a very
close match that's gonna be decided in
the 12th game that's my prediction but I
think Wesley if he keeps up the form you
did yesterday is what can you say
unbeatable well yeah if that's the big
if
we don't have inside information we
don't know if we got 14 hours of sleep
last night but guys if you take if you
take Fabi from day one and Wesley from
day two who do you pick
I mean Abby yeah I mean that's one's
rough I mean Bobby play like a beast on
day one Wesley on day two played that
rook d7 sweet mom against knocker I'm I
was I went to bed thinking about that
move like right now you were just like
that and demolished Hikaru Nakamura yeah
it's a tough one definitely a pick'em
but look at the thing who comes in for
him one of the things definitely stands
out in my mind again fab not taking
anything away from Fatih he played just
a terrific match Lulu
Lanier was in perpetual time trouble
throughout all the match in most of the
games and what we saw conversely in the
games between Anaka and Wesley is Wesley
was playing an amazing number of really
good moose rather quickly and time
wasn't really a big issue in that match
and so you know for fabbi he was really
getting a lot of points from the the
time the time pressure was a huge factor
well you know moves good most caused you
to think but it is true the instincts
have to be on and it looks like a way we
go these players are now going to play
the finals two of them let's hope
they're in great form and we see some
epic games as games have begun the game
has begun exactly and we have a rule
Lopez with Bishop b5 a6 no more Berlin
at least not for this moment and Bishop
a4 on the board right so Fabiano said
that against Lanier he decided to start
the Berlin because the more the sharper
lines he played on day one he was afraid
that Dominguez would have all of
Wednesday night to review them Tuesday
night rather to review them and he
didn't want to get into that but now
he's going back into those sharper lines
and it looks like we have
typical what's the name of this opening
again it's ordinary and hyper linen
targets all right the Ark and gold muler
variation and the theoreticians are
coming up with all kinds of ways of
labeling it's very tricky I just like
Archangel that sounds good yeah exactly
and at night a three and again this is a
very very well known variation you'll
have to go back to the World
Championship match between Magnus
Carlsen and Sergei and Sergei nearly won
a crucial game with white remember that
that that World Championship match and
how close it was at the very end
Magnus pulling it out in the tiebreaker
yes I played in my hometown of New York
City definitely was epic indeed and we
see here Fabi playing with castles
sacrificing the pawn on b5 that the
temporary measures blacks not worried
about that he thinks that he'll be able
to get easy play and compensation what's
the deep on at the moment is under heavy
fire so you see there as we saw keep
capture with the jeep on G takes f 3 in
the position if you may show that and
then after 9h 5 we get the block down
trying to get that Knight to f4 and you
don't want to get your Kings side locked
down for too long with the Queen showing
up on that side so you flight f4 Knight
f4 bishop therefore an ef-4 in as game
and that is the position we currently
have as we g4 Knight 7 is played and
that B file little feature in quite
nicely for black as well as he's got
that pressure down that line so at some
point you're gonna see some some kind of
trickery on that that diagonal as well
it's like both players that were just
waiting for that side to be reconciled
in the meanwhile on the Kings side
Wesley saying hey listen I I'd like to
pick up that palm for free if I could
queen g4 takes f4 and maybe on a good
day I'll also get a chance to use the G
file I'll put my name in the corner King
h1 rook g1 slide over and
maybe my bishop on c2 will show up the
nice part about whites Center especially
the the center pounds from b2 2 C 3 e 2
d 4 is that they're trying to keep that
Bishop on b6 out of the game and we've
just seen C 5 by the way to try to break
that Bishop out of its little cage
that's because if we play d5 trying to
resolve it that way then it really gives
you some nice squares to later C's on so
instead after C 5 we saw dkc 5 Bishop c5
and then that temple gaining before but
that Bishop 1 b6 is a strong piece
that's had a lot of weaknesses in wine
can be 5 c5 I believe it I'm I'm hearing
was a novelty by Fabiano and you played
it superfast um who do you like here yes
96 by the way was just played if black
can get those dark squares it could be
very nice for him but if you're gonna be
able to just post a night up on f4 like
mean g3 Queen f6 right and like you say
going for the dark squares
hey both sides have their their Trump's
White has the lights where black
obviously doing well on the dark squares
I'm the pawn grubber in the family over
here guys so I have to you know put out
my hand and say okay I'll take the white
pieces simply because of the extra hard
well I'm not a pawn grubber and never
have been and I look at this position
it's so dynamic yes you have a passport
on beef on before but the pawn on c3
looks very vulnerable the dark squares
look super vulnerable as well so to me
unless White's going to prove something
with that wayward night sitting on a
three I honestly don't see how you push
this position very easily now that last
move well we're in this mobile you play
Queen f6 he didn't play Queen f6 just
yet okay so I was thinking about Queen
f6 right so I think it's important to
note that for from black standpoint the
organization of blacks of White Army is
critic
because if y can let's say play Knight
c4 and somehow sneak his knight if your
Bishop leaves to III and then to d5 now
White has a lock on the position
give me those three moves and I'm
feeling like yeah I move my king do
everything that we said because you can
hit c3 properly he 5f4 so instead this
move d5 what a contentious move giving
his opponent two connected passed pawns
but saying I want to get as much space
as possible and I'm going to also
pressure your pawn on c3 now this move
is bold
this move is absolutely like no because
no [ __ ] about it Bishop c7 is another
idea another way to kind of try to
capitalize on those dark squares get
Knight f4 and Queen h4 and potentially
obviously after you move your queen I
don't want to trade means here that much
is black because your is the one that's
weaker look at this key moment though
the idea of rook to d1 rook to d1 after
d5 then a 1 D 1 yes sorry rook a 1 D 1
arguing that hey what's the deal with
your weak pawn that you just pushed all
your dark score your plans for dark
square domination gonna be enough as
right now that's the second pony's I
ain't sharp as sharp as you could get
guys this is the first game of the match
we're getting a delightful position
right out the gate yet again well okay
so let's continue with Bishop c7 I would
imagine I mean after all trying to
conquer the f4 square is what it should
all be about for black so how are we
gonna meet this move Bishop c7 we can we
play f4 I mean I it looks very very open
and very but hey gotta try it
exactly well yeah otherwise I mean
allowing the if you move the Queen and
allowing the knight - little rest on f4
that doesn't look very good okay so
something I don't know
now keep it going no Epps takes Queen f6
we know K keep hitting keep hitting
stuff absolutely five and shift your
queen over to c6 guard your pawn keep
the pressure on c3 and s
especially keep that darn night out of
the game that night cannot come back in
the game in a good way you've got to
make sure that doesn't happen this is a
that's a radical decision well I wanted
to make I wanted to vacate situ so I
could make room for the night to quickly
go to d4 I'm assuming Hg I don't know if
I really like you make sense yeah giving
a passer in the middle of the board and
we do have this exact position on the
Midway players have caught up with us
right not before night C before the
bishop takes on g6 every single move
played exactly to this point and we have
this variation on the board these
players are playing sterling chess at
the moment but I mean they're lose that
we see yes Maurice wow they're playing
really well today I just want to make a
point about this position look at
White's pawn structure it's all over the
place I mean all the pawns are on dark
squares yes but black is looking to
crack that structure at some point the
pawn on c3 is backward white has those
hanging pawns in the middle of the board
the isolated H pawn the weaker King but
he's up upon again I'm not a pawn
grubber so I look at this position I
think black if he could just organize
something he could pinch it all these
weaknesses somehow but is it enough and
by the way there's also there's also a
d4 break that that black could play just
to try to crack the structure so your
move Bishop your move Bishop takes on g6
yeah that makes some sense as well so
some tactics and whoa Wesley played
eight four ignoring Fabi completely
saying I'm gonna go for my own old play
like whoa also giving us guys
compromised now yeah yeah very
uncompromising move H to H for
eyeballing h5 and patan
actually you know utilizing the G file
and giving King H to my goodness it's
really a double-edged move I must say
I'm assuming he's got D for all worked
out in a nice way you can't
well actually I suppose you could
legitimately take on d4 with the pawn
I was thinking rook takes before but
then I got teeth d5 and then Pathak's
just flare up whites whites Kings side
looks and like terrible but working a
was played instead hey rook a8 attacking
the knight that makes sense it's an
important move and challenging that
night we talked about it being on a bad
square night b1 looks miserable but is
it necessary play Knight d2
well the problem now is that one of
these things on g6 rook takes leaves the
bishop and unfortunately the pawn on c3
drops so we no longer have the time
tonight be wise for my big one too rook
d2 ok not happy not happy sequence
therefore wisely because Bishop is now a
threat in 1982 you get an intermezzo
Bishop takes on h7 check out for taking
back so right and I don't be one
actually it does a good job of
protecting the rook on detail as well as
the pawn on c3 yeah that's that's crazy
but better that night just such a good
job here I just feel like this position
I mean I love attacking don't get me
wrong but moving the Jeep on and the F
pawn with so many pieces left on the
board it feels like five you should have
something strong here it doesn't it the
thing is not sure I feel like it but
where is it yeah show me how do you how
do you actually pressure this position
you want to play something like f6 pawn
break the actual the actual acceleration
of your pieces is a problem the
repositioning of your forces to great
squares where do you put them like you
look around he's okay where does
Knight on g6 one Oh No maybe it's not me
where it is Bishop to b6 you want to
play yeah sure I just want to know where
your kings gonna go h2 I guess or h2
that's about Age 2 right because if you
go in the the white square I have d4
drag so you avoid that h2 is h2 is my
choice for sure Bobby has doubled on the
a line and played rook to a8 I'm not
sure where that the effort to aid I'm
not sure where that rook is going other
than supporting his own piece but I
think that's what it was all about it's
all about Jordan being keeping the
harmony and challenging white to come up
with something but daring white to play
as you're showing you as h5 and and then
whoa how do you get right through well I
think from Wesley's point of view when
he played to move h4 he was envisioning
forcing the night away provoking a move
like g6 and then he wants to utilize his
Bishop as well as his rook now if he's
going to allow this exchange sacrifice
that's the thing that would I would be
careful about I think the exchange
sacrifice might actually be very good
for for black but I can understand that
well in Wesley's mind if you can play
rook G to h5 get in the move f5 then
it's all going swimmingly well although
the dark squares do collapse a little
bit if g6 goes on the board for what
you're arguing there you could go back
sorry go back to this moment in time
when you played we go forward
nope we are having F a yes you have rook
F a dichotomy or your screen here we go
v so night so night after H 597 yeah and
your route to be met maybe by a queen
eight six as well that's that is a sharp
I mean a direct way of defending without
creating any weaknesses and the question
still comes about how do you move this
night on b1 to me when the stuff is the
fan which it looks like it's doing right
now black pieces are all there in the
game they're all playing right
yes it looks like a little pressure on
on wife's part but oh and clear pressure
on wise part but all of blacks pieces
are playing while white is down a night
for the moment so black just needs to
find some sequins and Wesley has played
Queen d3 further defending his [ __ ]
after after rook a8 correct
rookie I can only be met by Knight f8
right yes there's no there's no
immediate maybe Bishop b3 is a potential
threat you know but there's it doesn't
look like there's any immediate knockout
blow threatened with Queen d3 yeah
Bishop b3 is definitely a move that
you're gonna have to consider here
because that does have some spice to it
an h5 up I'll say h5 9 f8 now black's
knight is out of play so maybe white can
consolidate knowing that this one piece
is gone and you might go for the Bishop
b3 line trade off some rooks the night
leaves back to d2 and a different kind
of chess what is for track
I'm a queen C for this move not check
but Bishop e6 check actually was playing
yes
and I'm anticipating King hu sorry guys
I'm not getting an update on my board
over here I can't that's why right we
see everything so you're up to date on
your analysis no everything's cool
alright so King h2 is what we're
anticipating you don't really want to go
to h1 where there's gonna be a discovery
of some kind no I don't think so so
you're right I think we hasn't played it
quite yet but King h2 were expecting but
any bang as soon as King h2 is played
five he played d4 opening position
against that King this was exactly what
I was worried about for Wesley this
looks so scary to me for right but does
Wesley have it all planned out well is
he good understand that bad move because
looks like c4 will eventually happen and
your D pawn will block your Bishop and
he looks like he has played c4 and
fabi's Bishop now is just blocked by his
own pawn c5 can come at any point what
is the
ditional benefit of D for the game did
not open a long lines Fabi wanted to see
and instead it looks like the pawns are
just gonna be powerful no it's important
it's just too good
this move is too strong what are we
doing at that move
yeah no I think d4 was just a blunder I
mean something like Knight faz played by
the way maybe that one H to d4 c4 Bishop
David eight is what yeah and then I mean
an easygoing boy clicking on d4 is there
a reason why takes on h4 by anything
yeah Bishop b4 bishop even looks threat
big big threat and by the way wow that's
not such an easy threat to a sidestep oh
this is crushing because because d8 may
also be hanging yeah absolutely
68 and gotta worry about although Knight
of fate is is in the pit means if you
move oh that that means that rook is
actually overworked it's guarding the a2
rook well he does never takes D to check
to get out of any discovery on his room
that that we can Sabo now we're talking
defensive mode from for black black is
exactly White's pieces are definitely
better there is an issue with whites
King but it's not easy to exploit and
now he's hightailing it backwards with
Queen c7 this organization of his pieces
does not look correct and we'll oh isn't
that just like walking in the 93 to d5
with the tempo forcing the knight back
Knight c3 will can come next and h5
first Oh gasps Knight went back to f8
and now we expect a knight c3 and that
night I know we said we was out of the
game for so long it's a hero
oh man this is a completely crushing
Wesley coming where he came from
yesterday just coming right back and
saying yeah where I left off you see the
spanking I put on that guy in the first
three games yesterday let me do the same
thing to you game 1 Wesley so Oh Wesley
here Knight c3 look
just fantastic and the really nice part
about this is it's all coming with tempo
I mean 93 hits the rook on a 295 will
hit the Queen once we push the Queen
away then we even start thinking about
f4 f5 and our attack along the g5 plays
itself there's only one makes this is
only learning to worry about to watch
and it's the Queen
up here and it it has occurred c5 was
played instead of Knight c3 he played c5
and then instantly Queen c7 and talk
about a drowning man clutching at straws
he just wants to get any counter play he
can by bringing the Queen over to that
side looks like looks like a king maybe
you could just retreat your king and
bring your rook in the way but it is
getting in the tricky and you see Wesley
so there on the screen shaking his head
he's not sure that he has this under
control
yeah no I'm perplexed by the move c5 as
the advance you know push him can be
played any time get it that night on b1
which currently now this he's played
Bishop to e4 that was the other thing I
was going to say about Bishop to e4 just
to bring it over and potentially cover
the king if the king is forced to drop
back on the chief I'll don't they should
you too but this disposition has changed
a knight took he played 96 Queen d3 and
rook takes d2 and squares if we play
Knight takes t2 there's a little pesky
Queen eight four right and then f4 could
be in take our UNH 3 is ready but I'd be
more scared I'd be more scared of rook
to a - yeah and asking you to defend
everything about your position ok let's
start with Queen takes D you want to
take Queen instead yeah and in case of
Queen h4 check I'll drop my King back oh
he won I'm sorry we can't we got to
follow this game because look what's
going back and he he decided to play
Knight takes so he decided to take on 87
with check and then
way night takes is that the sequence
that happened he took the pawn in 87 in
our King AJ fabi's playing absolute
sacrificial chess he said forget about
the pawn on 87 I'm just gonna go for it
you can have the gift Bishop takes a
seven check King h8 three pawns
oh now three times been doing now don't
worry yeah you have a live board and
laughs okay we'll live and does black
have enough compensation on these dark
squares so much going on right now as
Queen h4 check looks like a move worth
looking at York we no longer have that
Queen h3 resource yes I mean how about
King G to h4 just play King gjo what
your oh there's no night at four track
because the d8 bishop will hang at the
end with mate after we say seven four
[Music]
you can't do that line Oh Fabi is trying
to figure out what to do now by the way
they're been playing so well did he play
King g2 or Kingi one it wasn't which is
not yet on the board we hate working you
to King G we play if we play Queen f4
right away does that do anything
that's an interesting line and it looks
like Fabia's instead simply played the
quiet Bishop to East oh oh he did play
Queen h4 check King g1 and now Bishop to
e7 I mean it doesn't even look like a
threat is in the position although maybe
Knight takes e5 might be a move you
think about here fronted by Bishop takes
on c5 there's crisscross action that
black has with that rook on the seventh
and the queen unable to depart because
of the the knight on D to talk about its
complex position it's not clear to me
exactly I when I'm under attack I see my
opponent's got all of these people
pieces hovering around like
I'm looking to trade us without actors
oh nice a caffee six rook F 2 and now
Queen to g4 with check why they look out
for a queen d1 action I mean look g2
there is the possibility of also there's
a rook a e1 and the pawn on f4 is
hanging that's what I don't like was
leaving my right my pawn hang in there
and I just weaned I just heard thunder
and lightning outside let's catch up
with the players as the position we have
in the board is right at with Bishop h4
king h2 and Bishop h4 and I don't like
this for white this there's so much
action in this position he played rook
g2 did did white and Queen takes f4
check give me one pawn back King h3 rook
a1 and it is black attacking despite
being two pawns down this looks
terrifying it sure does I have three
horse mating attack coming and he's up
those two pawns he's got no Pripet
there's no Queen d8 Medina f3 looks like
it should shore up the position well I
have after-work h1 check you can now
which piece are you gonna put on because
rook h2 is me rotates - is this Queen g3
mate game over
so we'll have to play Knight h2 you have
to play this problem that poor Knight
nicer home right and Wesley shaking his
head again you know he didn't want to
see this position when he was up that
material dominating position
you mentioned yaz nice III should have
been played now this Knight is sitting
on
we'll square the king some kind of
Bishop move f2e one threaten the Queen
h4 mate but the problem is the bishop is
guarding d8 and you will give him the
chance to play some kind of perpetual
action with with Queen back Queen down
and back and all that so I don't think
it means perpetual we have seen a
repetition of position at least once
working by compelling yeah my screen is
frozen guys so I can't see but basically
what happened was rook e1 was played and
then ninety four then five he went back
to h1 with Jack and then Knight H 2 so
this has already been repeated and I was
working one it looks like Fabiano is
saying 94 and then he's happy to take a
girl in this position he didn't see a
way to increase those those three pieces
that are and there it is if he's a
repetition of position what a fake is
what this size is going to be like a
tree that's Game one of the match man I
love this opening fabi's playing he's
just freestyling freewheeling and okay I
got a worse position but let's go show
me what you got this is rapid chess the
seconds are ticking down what a game
this is the kind of draws that you could
say okay okay we'll take that amazing
stuff let's do this every game no Berlin
come on five seriously we're gonna be
right back for the second game in this
mass or is it already underway it's
gonna be underway in a few minutes yeah
okay seconds potentially yes when you
look at when you look at this kind of
chess I mean what can you say they it
looked like you said you grabbed some
material you consolidate you should be
able to take it home but you make one
misstep and these guys find counterplay
out of thin air true but I'm still
reeling from the decision I think it was
at move 33 by
Wesley to play the move c4 c5 when I'm
looking in this position I'm saying to
myself Knight c3 is an absolute screamer
how can you not yeah play Knight c3 I
mean every fiber of your being should be
to bring your pieces you know centralize
your pieces get them active and he left
it at home he just said I'm not gonna
lie for your knight on d5 when you could
have it on h2 yes right it was a really
well played game over uh some hiccups
there at the end but overall we're in
store for games like that we're gonna be
in for a lot of fun but uh let's take a
look at some clutch moments from the
past as we're ready to get set up for
game 2 in the last round of the
inaugural Sinquefield Cup in 2013 soon
to be world champion Magnus Carlsen
declined to draw offer that would have
won him the tournament the rest is
history
but these guys might be getting fatigued
and that was where a lot of their
interviews they spoke about their
stamina and the need and it looks and
looks like there might have been a
verbal offer of a draw in this position
and Magnus not twirling upon the vine
offer to drop and Magnus is thinking
about when Berlin Magnus thinking
fascinating to see if he makes a move
with the fact that's his 70,000 has
literally been handed to him it's more
than just and he has been he made
incredible the cool the draw offer well
I decided to continue with 70 grand in
his pocket he didn't win no more there's
nothing beneficial to him to making
another move absolutely nothing and he
has actually decided to continue playing
and a lot of other results to enter and
the knight on a 1 is trapped incredible
lines but it looks as though if
Magnussen now plays this move Knight to
c4 after king d8 he will be
at least have a big advantage and we
have it and there it is magnus carlsen
is the ce field cup winner the champion
he's sleeping closer to 2900 we have a
comment on Twitter that magnus carlsen
turned let's draw off her down that's by
michael waters because he previously
said he wanted to be world champion and
2,900 by the end of 2013 and he gets one
step closer with his victory at the same
field cup leading him far ahead of his
rivals and securing the $70,000 the
trophy and more importantly I mean
making a fabulous impression to fans all
over the world
[Music]
quite a trip down memory lane there to
the very first Supino scub Wow we have
year to sing field cup/champions
um fighting and is innovative new format
and what a game one thrilling double
King pong you know what they played
double King Khan like that it makes me
want to throw out the Sicilian and start
playing e5 oh man that is absolutely
tremendous
that game was fantastic like I said I'm
hearing thunder and lightning outside
and I'm seeing it on the board yeah so
your screen is freezing up from all that
we got to get you being able to see yeah
absolutely
let's hoping we get the technical issue
out the way as we got the specialist who
can control your screen from afar but at
the moment it's half half in the match
and exactly what and just absolutely
beautiful game we were treated to in
Game one two superstars of chess showing
their best stuff with positional lessons
that's what I love about watching the
best players in the world play rapid
they're so good that when they play
classical chest some of the positional
lessons are embedded in the moves and
you might not see them but when they
play rapid they do make mistakes they're
human and then you get to see this idea
of making your worst piece by hair nice
c3 to d5 seems came so quickly
the Yasir Sarah Wan who who is course
always known for his great strategic
genius when he was in the top 10 players
in the world yes well that was tough I
mean for me I think of the positional
instincts of the player is a second
nature I mean they just play those moves
what is amazing for me is their tactical
awareness and their ability to analyze
these tactical variations so quickly
like well how can I say human
calculators and they're underway in
getting to in Berlin we have yeah and II
know I could just yeah I I have it on my
board that's the only thing I can see I
can't see the players I can't see the
light position I can't see yourselves
that's no that's why that's
there is a - to not having our staff in
front of us I don't know if Jen humor is
watching but we miss you Jen I
definitely love when she there's
something wrong and she comes in and
says all right I'll fix it it's all
fixed now relax
it got refreshed they got refreshed I
can see you guys now you now you're back
in business
all right here we go you're saying this
Berlin from Fabi
well at least Wesley chose to go into
this line this is not the sharpest of
positions this is definitely some
positional chests you check out when you
see this kind of game now in the match
between linear and Fabio B was getting
under pressure in this ending and so now
he's getting the plate on the white side
and seeing if he can pressure Wesley so
we've just seen the move h7
h5 which is very very common in this
Berlin as black tries to play the move
h5h forward locking down the majority
that white enjoys on the kingside yes we
usually kind of groan when we see the
Berlin show up because black tends to be
able to play solidly and stop white from
getting away with anything expansive but
Dominguez showed some nice ideas against
Bobby that he's excited you say wait a
minute I think I could play white
against the Berlin if we if blacks gonna
handle it that way I've seen my personal
opinion is for amateurs that playing the
white side liberland is a great idea
because I think that it's more of an
opening that requires a grandmaster very
strong master hand is black white white
plans seem like easier to come by so if
you were not a professional player and
your opponent has the Berlin against do
I mean what's not to like about the
position at first lads it takes such
deep understanding as Kramnik prove
against garry kasparov
to really appreciate how supple and how
many possibilities
Black's position has later on what's
funny by the line is the bad rep that
the Berlin had for so many decades
literally decades and then you talked
about chronic rehabilitating the line in
his World Championship match against
Kasparov in in a two thousand and two
thousand and that match took Gary's
title from him yes yes the darn thing is
like how dare you probably this inferior
open against me and he can do a thing
with it and I remember Holly hundra
saying to me Alejandro Ramirez grand
master of course one of our key
colleagues here
he said remember yes he said the Berlin
is the main line to me in the rear Lopes
you mean it's the main line to Berlin is
a sideline in the rural open for so many
years the main lines are morphine
defense of the [ __ ] any the Russians
might call it but it has become the line
that the top players in the last 15-20
years play all the time no question
about it and I remember back in the US
Open in 1975 in Lincoln Nebraska and
there was our own Arthur biz wire Arthur
busy wire and played deep Earl in the
Berlin ending his entire life and we got
we played a lot of blitz together Arthur
and I even though I was only 15 at the
time you really like to you really like
to play blitz and he said yes sir you've
got to you should learn to play the
Berlin defense it's great you get the
two bishops
you love the two bishops and I was like
mm no no and later in 1980-81 and the
World Championship match with between
Viktor Korchnoi
and Anatoly Karpov Viktor Korchnoi
prepared a Berlin and he played the
Berlin but he didn't play the Berlin
ending he recaptured with the b-pawn and
put his night back on b7 got killed
killed and the Berlin Pazzaglia door
29 years you're you're gone goodbye at
least at least in the world championship
level nobody wants to touch that
position what we see here is a name by
the way those who are looking and saying
why doesn't block just castle
well that's move eight cleaned all that
up after Queen takes d8 check and the
King took back there's no casting for
you and this is where we get this ending
and that's one of the things that the
people may have been concerned about
that poor King sitting in the middle of
the board not able to castle while white
is able to organize his pieces very
rapidly
however it's that bishop key bishop the
one now sitting on f5 by black stops
easy penetration as does the bishop on
e7 so it's not easy for white to get the
incursion into the position as one with
exactly and that's what's giving black
these good positions very solid and
sometimes black plays this thing in his
sleep just very easily and quickly and
as you see here
he's already up two minutes on the clock
almost against Caruana
only using a minute as Wesley so at
least a minute of his original time they
do get a five-second increment to get to
this position one of the reasons it's a
it's a wise opening to play in rapid
black being well-prepared just able to
blitz out all these moves yeah what were
you gonna say I was gonna say that
version of Cobian told me that h5 is
actually a slide line very rarely played
it has been played it's not a novelty
that it seems to me that Wesley's
preparation he's out prepared fabbi as
you can see from the clocks and also
from the fact that Wesley is looking
very comfortable with this move Bishop
f5 and just saying to fabbi okay why did
you put your knight on e4 oh so you
could play this move Bishop g5 by the
way it's interesting that you mentioned
Wesley's face and seeing him on camera I
read an interview with Nakamura where he
said that a lot of times people give up
their poker faces when they're playing
in these new online prestigious sort of
it
yet the other player can see them so
watch out for that when you see a player
make a mistake and indicate it on their
face that that's just as dangerous as it
would be in an over the board game well
most setups they can also see their
opponents camera well wonder because
this is the position where just our
trade where garry kasparov this is the
this is the situation where Gary had
this monster movie 6 when he got a
chance to beat down kramnik after taking
after losing his title I think you
mentioned it was Novgorod yeah yeah in
this event and this movie six has become
a thematic move for white in this line
and if y can successfully engineer east
6 he could put a whole lot of hurt on
the black position at the moment a 6
looks tempting I think the whole idea
plan behind a 6 has to rest on how are
you gonna meet f6 where is this night
gonna go are you going to sacrifice the
night for a number of pawns or are you
gonna try to drop the knight back to e4
and offering the pawn this way I think
that's the question that
fabbi has to ask himself you play e6 and
you're proud but then after the move f6
a big question to be answered
do you play Knight f7 or do you play 94
and decided instead to go for g4 whoa
allowing hg hg hg and there's a pawn
hanging on h3 what's the deal takes
takes what are we missing
c6 looks like f6 again can you that
might be it now you play e6 then after
f6 you take take rook d7 that is some
funky sacrifices here and it is a bird
Bishop h3 is on the board Knight takes
on h3 we're expecting rook h3
oh pardon me he didn't play e63 my
apologies took on h3 immediately which
we expect must be rook h3 now worst is
he gonna play kztours you're gonna go
for six I think you got to play e6 King
g2 we do have working creating effects
guys yes all about to see so fabi's it
down upon that's clear but he's got this
position with the pawn on e6 and he's
he's gone for the water we know whatever
we go whatever it is he's got in there
looks like just water that big old
bottle of his and he's saying I'm
blasting through with this move I don't
think well you definitely can't take
this pawn on e6 you just know if an with
a six and if you play King f7 we have 95
check your exactly marches back to me
ever choice a piece of the take I'll
take the rock yes yeah that would be a
nasty port there Knight g5 question I
think we have to ask is what do we do if
we take the pawn the King ghost King f2
because you've got to defend the night
and then I just had chill and say okay I
am to bonds up game position that's what
happened and it's got to be rook d7
because what else are you gonna eat it's
seven okay makes sense White has lost
white is now in the game position down
to pawns who founds that's what I'm
thinking with the much more active
pieces and threatening everywhere if he
plays a rook to d7 he'll be hitting the
C he'll be hitting everybody on the on
the video later he has played the move
rook to d7 on I'm Tory I'm thinking rook
a4 to defend f7 you can't take with the
pawn because that would hang the rook
oops don't want to do that and if you
take with the rook I'm just trading some
think you can look at for and if you go
rook c7 now I'm thinking all night f4 oh
you're gonna get rook f7 sighting okay
this is how you that's a no no that's
nothing for white that's nothing but no
that's how you say I'm thinking
you're thinking why it's worse because
of the two pawns I'm thinking yes white
is trying to show her something with his
rook on the seventh rank I mean I think
why why should I worry about Paula know
and I'm so active so you're saying that
after a night eh for work at 7:00 you
Claybrook takes half three check you
can't play rook takes f7 because then
pawn a seven king f7 you lose the night
right 94 can always be answered by King
g3 there's not a loss of a piece right 9
h4 and off would be answered by King g3
so rook takes e7 night h4 can always be
answered by King g3 it's not a loss of
the piece the seventh and what and I
feel like I'm threatening your position
with your King on h4 you feel like
you're you're not castling amazing me
I'm gonna play King g4 I'm gonna take on
f7 you're gonna have to put your King on
f8 that pawn is gonna stay there you're
gonna trade this partner I mean this may
be a draw but how can I possibly be
worse when you down a rook to in the
attack it's just it's just white here
Wow all my life all my life all I wanted
to do is win pawns and now I'm all these
pawns out but you're saying it's not
it's not it's not winning for black kids
well you're only one in this position
and you're not that's true you know
you're not to it more exactly
well okay I thought the King was a bit
stranded over here I guess it's okay for
white what can I say
so what what is the current position no
we have recently seven there has no
there's been no rook f4 and Wesley who
had been keeping an eye space this
entire game has gone into a deep think
in this precise position trying to
figure out exactly how to liquidate well
it looks like neutralized he's played a
couple of moves but it looks like
there's there's a problem
he played rook CA and you see the image
of the bar just went nuts
rook F semi and a knight Knight FA
Wow yes this that is bizarre to me my
way of thinking is because that King is
really in deep water after and by the
way you're pointing out a great move yes
as you pointed out we're being told as
well you did spot the winning move there
is rook h1 and it's resigns rook h1
would win the game because 96 kicking
their legs out from under the rook can
be met by Knight e5 and rook h1 has been
played Bobby also spotted this move and
the game is over
this is crushing as Murray's mentioned
he's got 96
I forgot about 95 Wow yeah knowing the
threats protecting that key rock wow
this is a great infinity header and
threatening matin 1
that's right rookie 4 check doesn't help
you because we just trade those babies
off and pick off your rook on CA this
one I was talking about yes that rook on
the back rank it wasn't active and this
was a big problem to think about I
didn't expect to win a rook but 19 the
activity of the white pieces meant that
black had to be a bit more careful and
rook c8 ultra passive move was not the
solution
he should have played look it looks like
a huge blunder and well opportunity
knocks and fabbi capitalized with this
fabulous move rook h1 and Fabien Scot
now settings resignation ha ha
I see half half as a result here that
must be the score in the match because
now Fabi has won 1-0 oh how sweet it was
and here's Wesley trying to figure out
what he did wrong as you see him here on
camera saying what did I do
he's gonna notice that that move rook c8
was a howler the culprit yeah who would
have thought that this game would end in
25 moves so the Berlin's not so dry all
the time
but our current score guy says now
Fabiano has one and a half points -
Wesley sews half a point after two very
competitive games open the Ray Lopez
very different games indeed but are we
gonna see a real of has themed attic or
you think somebody's gonna switch it up
at some time at some point they will but
you think it's gonna happen soon like in
Game three or four well we'll find out
soon as we are gonna take a quick
commercial break and then we'll be back
for Game three of day one of the final
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever that we stay connected to
carry on that mission we are currently
offering 24 weekly classes online
through our YouTube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home students can enjoy all
the benefits of our scholastic chess
initiative digital our Scholastic
outreach continues with virtual chess
classrooms and scholastic tournaments
and scouts BSA mayor Bedford stones on
behalf of everyone at the st. Louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
world chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 SLU
partner with the same Lewis Chess Club
to start a top tiered collegiate chess
team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we are back with the clutch chest
finals we are heading into Game three of
six today but let's review the schedule
for those of you for just joining us we
are in Game three as I mentioned so
we've got Game three in Game four then
we moved to our clutch games which are
gonna be worth a double points and
finally tomorrow we're gonna do it all
again
except tomorrow the clutch game they're
gonna be worth even more so you're not
gonna want to miss any more of the
action exactly and this is where we
stand after that howler bye
Wesley well it's one and a half points
for Viviano and just a half for Wesley
but so many points left up for grabs
today and here we're gonna see Wesley
know getting a crack with the white
pieces so I'm sorry Bobby have you who's
waiting in right
no no Wesley Wesley I thought I was
missing I thought it was miss reading
the board no they haven't started the
game yet that's why okay so when three
and five you're about to start any
minute and wensley will have the white
pieces and I'm sure Wesley
still is smarting from that first game
as well right that was the second time
he found himself up three pawns and
didn't win the game it's really been a
shading because he again against naka it
was like that and I'm sure he was a
three points at some point in this last
game right it was and then they ate well
h5 yeah so he was up three palm trees on
second time in this event where he was
up three pawns and failed to win drawing
both times once in that game five
against naka and again drawing in Game
one here against Fabi so Wesley shaking
his head like I'm three points up I'm
supposed to win these exactly and he
manages to barely hang on for a draw in
this last one so he's he really
underestimated the counter play a fatty
with that Queen h4 check so will Willie
repeat the opening experiment
why not I think that why not and will
fabbi say a wait a minute
that Archangel variation really didn't
go very well in that move F for that
Wesley quickly played in the opening
showed that Wesley was prepared for fab
ease Archangel business we'll see maybe
Fabio play never men there you go after
just pasting it in twenty three moves
after getting mauled or at least coming
under heavy pressure against the Minka's
yesterday and now crushing it you know
that Berlin is not looking so solid all
of a sudden at least not in rapid little
a little shaky to be sure by the way d4
mm-hmm Wesley says look and ambidextrous
I can mix it up I can play E for or one
d4 and look at this embracing the benoni
is fab e he's one of the very rare elite
grandmasters in the world prepared to
played the Benoni defense and he's done
it
and most people would just say bad that
white had so many ways to try to make
you suffer
but Fabi shown that he doesn't mind
he'll play some all kinds of different
lines it looks like they're going into a
mainline variation right main line I say
for us yes right nowadays they might
disagree what the main line is but this
one is the the classical one the
old-school one that was tried and true
and supposed to give white something but
black I just kind of play
just to remind the old-timers that might
be out there with us
rookie 892 a six this is the Boris
Spassky Bobby Fischer variation you may
remember it for the t-shirts they make
these days nine eighty five Bobby
Fischer Game three needing a win played
this very unorthodox night aged five it
worked like a charm and that was all she
wrote that's the history so let's see
what the current setup is
by the way it looks like rook e8 was
played yes we got all these movie
tonight
and then Knight d7 you can keep going
and Queen Queen c2 look at this they're
playing all the moves and not Knight h5
but Knight e5 by fabbi
inviting the move F to F for I don't
know what the theoretical risky move for
sure Knight g4 could be played and
because Knight g4 by the way just to
make sure everybody understands don't
want to see the night landing on my
front doorstep 93 which is why I played
the move Knight here their tactics here
yes their tactics would a 94 tactic is
its position and if you take back you
got to deal with some Bishop d4 or Trek
action and yeah I get it
that's my hair black comes in this
position you don't want to go there so
Wesley decided to go super positional
with the move a5 quite dramatic here and
if I quickly play rook being instantly
so black is going for everything he can
be 5 will be played not be 6 but be 5 so
they can keep pressuring white from the
wings looking for the move before
eventually as he got moves forward and
was leaning now and I remember the great
Hungarian player lyashko dish he'd love
to play this variation as white and
after for example move like rook a3 you
often saw Leo spraying the move Knight
c3 to d1 what was his idea sometimes
black plays g5 to secure the e5 square 4
is a knight and the rook can swing the
cross and if the rook isn't swinging
across the other idea is to put the
knight on the C 4 square so very a game
that then it's very rich in strategy Oh
b 2 e 3 3 and now that's a
if I play Bishop to b4 and tradeoff
waits for a bishops no very happy has
black you're not gonna let you do it
you're not it yeah you're so averse to
that idea trading the legs squared fish
outs the head entertain the possibility
why is the reason why I'd really like to
do that yes if you'll notice in the
Venona a lot of times my feet my my feet
are tripping over each other I meant to
say my pieces are tripping over each
other
your minor pieces exactly exactly so
getting rid of that LightSquared Bishop
is beautiful but look at this actually
Fabi
Wesley rather did allow it I think you
playing free right you think so yeah you
were gonna think that's a hundred
percent I I didn't even consider any
other move beside f2 f3 for exactly the
reason that you were stating which is
that the trade of minor pieces is
usually a strategy that lack embraces
it's not the major pieces in the problem
that's the problem with the benoni it's
the minor pieces and he played a very
intriguing move a night back to certain
from 'if I've night drop back to d7 I
wouldn't have guessed us the first move
that you would consider is black but
that was what fabbi did now and I'll say
I picked up the benoni
for a very short period of time in my
career before I got some common sense
knocked into me and one of the things
you mentioned is this business of
trading off the light square bishop is
something that black generally wants to
have but he also he also recognizes that
the paw information is worse for him the
pawn structure is worse
why does have that great space that pawn
on d5 is really a bone in the throat but
black can generate counter play and if
you don't click correctly black will get
some ideas that will combine some kind
of f59 h5 f5 push a potential b7 b5 at
the right moment and try to get play the
problem with the position is players
like yasss erawan who are so happy to
sit
there and make you suffer grab a space
and say you're not doing anything for a
while I'm just gonna let you sit there
and wonder what to do none of your brace
will work and then I'm gonna come after
you with some well time f-4e five idea
so this is the challenge can fobby time
it out correctly and now as we're
looking at this position there is the C
4 square that black has conceded to
white in this position early yeah
and that's something that white is
saying yeah I'm happy about that sooner
or later I'm gonna take advantage of my
Trump's and whites poor information but
for that beep on is beautiful black has
the week a six pawn the week d6 pawn
those two things will be buttons in the
long run so the end games are favoring
white I gotta say hobbies playing very
risky chess for sure in these games we
have black pieces absolutely no question
and it almost feels like he's embracing
double-edged positions where he's a bit
on the precipice he's been he's willing
to take an awful amount an awful amount
of risk I want to say as black now here
the problem with the desirable Knight c4
is it hangs the pawn on b3 I would love
it if I could play him of like Queen c4
for example - if I I would love it if I
could get my opponent to passively move
the rook to rock yeah I was about to say
the problem with Queen c4 is it blunders
my bishop on b2 because of Knight takes
e4 and my minor pieces are hanging so
we've got a blunder alert here because
Wesley did the same thing in a different
setting
he played rook a3 Knight takes e4 and
Wesley is in there oh if I go 1984
Bishop takes b2 and that's a huge
problem to the Queen
as the bishop you're in trouble and it's
a take on g7 then he just takes on d2 as
has occurred in the game and you you do
keep your Bishop if you're white but
it's not gonna do any good for you
because there's no way to get that
battery on that long diagonal that you
want to be able to make black blacks not
worried about this position as he can
always stop any energy along that
diagonal this is just a pawn he dropped
and this is the kind of tactical
possibilities that it the benoni is
known for this is definitely sort of a
hustle variation I got to admit you play
it because you say it's dynamic and you
baby works positionally but you channel
your inner tall and say I'm playing
something sharp you watch out and if you
won't look at some of the Venona games
that tower play back in the day now
those were games that inspired us to
play the Pannonian at the moment Fabi
with a dominating beautiful position on
the board up upon clean he's got open
phosphorus rooks he's got a target on b3
and Wesley is in trouble
hoping against hope that he can save
this game well he has to try to start by
really eight line right just play and
it's such an iconic idea right and in
the benoni or so you enjoy it's like
night 84 uncovering the bishop it shows
that you to be constantly vigilant just
knowing that a patterns there is not
enough but wisly will try his best to
get played look at this move Knight g3
you're looking at playing Knight f5
check pawn takes a5 Queen g5 check
getting in there with the Queen and
creating high chances of perpetual is a
tactically alert or if you're going to
give your the the the tactic prize so
far you got to be Fabi every single for
sure every single game game one we saw
it with a dead position just somehow
with a flurry of crazy ideas getting
himself back in the game Gabe - we saw
Wesley blunder not alert with rook to c8
and now again
Wesley not alert with rook to a3 and
Fabi punishing any single mistake that's
play
yeah he's really taking advantage of his
opportunity to be sure I'm anticipating
fabbi playing the move rookie fight as
you were mentioning Jennifer Knight f5
check it is an annoying threat because
of the follow-up Queen g5 so rookie 5
would both simultaneously protect cover
the f5 square as well as reinforce the
attack with rookie 5 that's wrong in the
Estonian when we see rookie 6 Queen b3
and now the D part is hanging anyway so
rook takes d6
it looks like you should be able to take
on d5 in this position yes right because
might have fun now the move Queen takes
b3 was a big surprise for me
I thought he I thought fabbi was just
dropping back with his queen ready to
lunch on d5 as well as b3 so this move
Queen takes b3 allowing 64 that copper
deal it has occurred 66 Knight takes on
d5 and this this knight on d5 is now in
a precarious position only defended by
the rook in the queen and f4 okay f4
would have won the night we're being
told blunder alert and f4 would have won
a piece nicely not alert again missing a
devastating shot f4 chasing the rules
work has no way to defend the night he
would have won a piece with this move
instead he opted for h4 what a missed by
both players in this critical moment Wow
I mean we were loading Fabiano a moment
ago for his tactical alertness and both
players were blinded by that opportunity
f4 was a screamer missed Queen it looks
like a very good move
that is what Bobby played and now trying
to remove any kind of ideas of age
five and eight chicks you're attacking
my work on a 114 the trade of Queens
right would argue by the way it's
interesting to think about that blunder
that occurred in the game because if you
if you know you blundered your brain is
in a totally different place right if
you know you mr. Winn oh man you're
you're kicking yourself but these two
haven't had the time to wonder did
something happen I mean we're getting
all excited but did something happen so
they're still in the flow of this
position and fabi's thinking yeah maybe
I should have gotten more but I'm up
upon
I've got winning chances Wesley's
thinking I got a fight for my life after
what happened in this darn game
blundering that Knight takes e4 shot so
try them all although the craziness
because of that mistake just simply not
a part of the psychology of the position
yeah I saw Wesley maybe flinch
afterward he played eight four maybe
we'll find out later in the interviews
but it seemed like although there's
gonna be so many exciting moments it's
my one might not rank and the top five
by the end of the day I did see some
strange mannerisms from him after that
move but we do have work did you want
Queen takes D to work takes D to and
this end game does Wesley have good
chances to save her do you think five
years back I know I I wouldn't say got
it I'd say that that he has good chances
of winning better chances of winning
than Wesley saving I remember remember
the grand chest for in Zagreb the
tournament where Wesley so it's Sergei
carry Aachen both players had missed
right you know like rook takes f5 and it
was right and a win in one move it was
just want to move and both players are
just unaware of it and Maurice I think
Sergei King after the game and you
interviewed him and you said oh you
could have won and he goes really and
you showed him the position he instantly
saw instantly saw it right you can blame
blitz rapid they're going quickly but
you just brought out a very important
moment and there many of those players
sometimes miss moves no matter how fast
or slowly they're playing they just
don't notice the idea
regarding him although I would say the
Rick f5 yeah it was it looked fairly
obvious to us
f4 here does look like a pretty obvious
move to chase the rook away here what
was the King so you might not feel great
about doing it when you look around
there's no alternative tactics just like
f4 what do you do there's no right
there's no threat somewhere that black
could generate something you might be
scared of so that would have been a
killer anyway right now it is white
who's trying to figure out how to
control for in this position and he's
played his pawn to h5 that sacrifice is
not one that white wants black once I
mean I was thinking good I was thinking
that the H problem was it was a
promising target where it before looked
like an intriguing idea
he played rook c8 and then came h5 and
now he's not missing h5 h6 iconic quad
that for right exactly exactly exactly
so now after well the question is this
rook ending I'm two pawns up but this
structure on the Queen side looks
terrible and I feel that White's chances
are actually strangely enough improved
oh yeah he has better chances of drawing
this two pawns down than being one pawn
down with the night still on this has
occurred yes yes yes and Wesley fighting
back heroically here
yes he has a winner but he was also
busted at one point so if he can make
this draw he he'll breathe a sigh of
relief and saying you know what I missed
though I missed a shot i blundered okay
he blunder - thank goodness I got out of
there without losing the game so he will
try
against all odds no I think this is a
good ending for for white to be thinking
this should be drawn these double rook
endings are notoriously difficult to win
even though you have a passed pawn
because your King cannot eject the
blockading pieces
and as we see here on this board White's
gonna be able to freeze black to defend
the pawn even though you're up upon he's
gonna freeze that and then his active
rook on d5 he can use that rook to just
float back and forth to keep your King
out of the game so not an easy technical
task at all
King g3 by the way was played a shoeing
rook takes h5 which of course would have
been my first temptation without a doubt
to take that pawn off the board but
Wesley is probably counting on the fact
that his two pawns on f3 g to do a great
job at killing the majority we have seen
King g6 defending the pawn and they say
no no no actually actually I take it
back I do want to take the pawn and I am
threatening rip check and Abby says well
it's a scraggy a scraggly islook
incarnates mine I want to keep it he's
played the move f5 okay but again how
does black plan to make real progress
here rooks III played roots III on the
board and you look at Lee you look at
this position and white continued with
rooks e6 rook d4 and this is the problem
now White has said your C pawn needs the
fence your only way to beat me is to
bring your key into the game but how can
you do anything with your King here
exactly as soon as white plays the move
f3 f4 the black king is not crossing to
the e5 square he won't be able to chase
the look away and it should be a
fortress draw King f6 on the board and
the only way claw me shook his head
there by the way he can tell you don't
win this position you never defend your
C pawn but White's not gonna fall for
any tricks you can't even create the
trick maybe
rook g8 would be the one sleeping trick
in the position I'm wondering even if
you get my Jeep on if I take directly if
I take on c4 if you're even dreaming of
winning this position as well no your
well no there you hung mate yes be
careful oh okay yeah be be careful
they'll be there's probably gonna be a
rook takes g2 rook c6 check first before
taking this bond and then and then we're
he makes upon so much die with a full
belly and if you like the same yeah I
with a full tummy
how does work beyond Oh feel right now
he was rushing the guy he let her slip
away he has played with a solid opening
like the Benoni where you get this great
tactic of course I'm being sarcastic
the baloney is not solid but the fact
that he put his opponent off balance and
got a great tactic but then failed Ewan
Birney is doesn't feel good because it's
like when you bring the Benoni out and
you do manage to get exactly what you
wanted which is the throw your point
about balance feels so sweet
doesn't it Jane for Wesley come on this
is a big result he he might be going
back and saying you know I'm not playing
really well who survived that one and
fabi's going to feel it without any
question at all you're gonna say man I
should have won that game mmm just like
way just like so now we've seen two
games where both players should have won
and did miss an opportunity right
opportunity so we've seen that shark
match tactical alertness that's what
it's all about
that gate that Gangwon has got to hurt a
lot more than this game because that
game one wesley was up three pawns Fabio
is only up one pawn in this game and we
do have I mean strangely enough the
players have gone down that whole
variation that we had been looking at
well there was nothing to play for the
only thing black had and this position
and it's just nothing to play for you
can't get your King in the game you
could you know there was nothing to do
about the C pawn so this is just this is
just draw easy it's just a drawing easy
no way to improve
with the king the king would be the
thing here and if you play King d6 I'm
thinking even rookie forecheck would get
the job done but you could even swing
the rook over yeah and it looks like
this is what's going on here the rook
has swung all over you
you just make no headway with your king
your black/white is also ready to put
the King on h6 at some point as well so
exactly that's easy easy draw easy joy
and the thing is even though it isn't
easy draw there is no draw offer before
move 60 in the match so 60 moves so
they're now currently is it move 45 yes
he here so they've got to make 15 more
moves before being able to offer a draw
they can repeat if they'd like find a
way to repeat maybe rook back and forth
but you see Wesley they're feeling like
he's no longer in any danger whatsoever
not even looking at the screen because
he knows he's strong enough with three
minutes on the clock
gonna handle this one Zac there'll be no
blunders here right and just to review
for those who are just joining us this
is a sweet tactic back on move yes move
19 that was where we're favi uncorked
Knight takes e4 winning upon and getting
himself into a winning position but
Wesley fought back and has got himself
into a drawn ending this is the current
position and fabbi has just played the
move rook g4 gg1
he's hoping that somehow he'll be able
to play rook to e1 to e4 and spear this
pawn on f4 well lot's of luck with that
I don't think he's gonna it's even close
we'll do something like a roof check
well Ricky yes okay sorry yeah recheck
it go ahead yeah I was about to say rook
check and move the king somewhere I
don't know where d5 and come back and
collect this guy that'll do it that'll
do it that'll do it indeed you know this
game game 3 leaves only one
our game before the clutch games right
the way this match has gone with all
these tactics and small misses those
games are gonna loom large because you
don't want to make this kind of blunder
when the games are worth two points so
this even moments in the games right on
even moments not the whole games but
just uneven moments where tactical
issues have cropped up in both their
play and right now we are looking at
what will be a drawing Brooks and Oh
King takes rookie for trading the rooks
Wesley did was the understood ing six
ke7
and now we're expecting King g7 only
move that's a that's a funny fancy drawn
very fancy yeah both and you see them
both getting up there and they agree
very clearly that this one is indeed
drawn and there it is
a draw miss there from Fabiano if he had
won this game and I think about winning
two games and the regular time control
is that I mean the regular scoring
system the regular games that it's nice
to go into those clutch games but the
two-point lead right even if you lose
one of them you're so even at the end of
the day but beyond oh I do like that
final girl at that Kingdom do we friend
looking at King f8 and then we threaten
King f5 and it's very sweet so here it
is
one point for a wrestler so who's got to
feel satisfied as you miss this nice
thank you for blow remember guys when
you're looking at sequence of hackers
you've got to go to the end you got to
look at all the different captures right
even the parry bet one of the very best
in the world went astray there so it's
one of the very best in the world went
astray then you better double check your
own work for sure
just before we go on and break I just
want to say that for me this was a very
very surprising decision a lot of benoni
players will understand that the base
bond the d6 bond that's the heart and
soul of the Benoni
you don't trade your d6 pawn for some
lousy pawn on b3
if fabbi had dropped back with the Queen
I have no doubts that he would have been
he would have gone on to success in this
position because both the b3 pawn as
well as the defi sponsor hanging and I
think that this would have been the
proper technique for
fabbi to win the game a big miss early
in this match I agree 100% with he as
that was definitely the move that was
called for and the players have to be
like cornerbacks in football you scored
on me I forget it I played a bad game
what happened huh what right anything
bad that happens to you you forget as
quickly as possible you do not want to
spend time ruminating trying to digest
what happened in that game haha you've
got the next game in front of you you
forget about anything else that's it
transpired before that so we will see
how they managed to do that but we will
go on break right now with a clutch
moment from one of the all-stars of
chess ding Lorraine nice in the 2019
Sinquefield Cup game Lorraine faced off
against world champion Magnus Carlsen
with previously 110 tiebreak matches in
a row the finish was one for the history
books as ding Lauren no doubt came into
this position thinking the draw is fine
I'll take white next game
Magnus got nothing with the white pieces
and ding Lauren if his attitude is wow I
had a whisper of a chance but it didn't
work out so what and it looks like this
is exactly what's happening as the first
game of the rapid playoff is draw now
some may say that that's a big success
for dinner and as he had Magnus in a
great position for for doing the Wren
and now he gets the white pizza's here
it is they both wanted badly Magnus has
tasted the
sweet nectar blowing from the sink field
cup twice already
ding Lauren never but Magnus wants to
win everything he plays in and ding
Lauren would love to get this for the
first time no in there it is a handshake
as we go to blitz Taylor inverse magnus
carlsen is it's gonna get faster and
faster here
both men playing so perfectly so far
they're fighting with just nine total 9
seconds 5 seconds total I think it's
gonna be a draw guys but why why does it
just move his bishop now moving his
check going back again there and this
looks like a heated repeat okay now
Bishop back to d4 it should not want to
draw he is torturing Magnus right now to
find the right moves Magnus down so once
my guess is lost sometimes Magnus has
lost on time digging the rim pushing him
over Wow dejected is now he has to come
back to even up the score just to stay
alive but it's good enough and we see
them starting that's a spectacular shot
winning the game the game is over
Queen D aegis fight chat Kevin work h1
is seen field Cup champion ding the ring
[Music]
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value Ches
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever that we stay connected to
carry on that mission we are currently
offering 24 weekly classes online
through our YouTube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home students can enjoy all
the benefits of our scholastic chess
initiative digital our Scholastic
outreach continues with virtual chess
classrooms in scholastic tournaments and
scouts BSA mayor Ben George Don's on
behalf of everyone at the st. knows
Chess Club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of clucks chest and this is our score we
just saw a draw in the third game of
rapid that gives Wesley one point
Fabiano Carroll a one-point lead but he
really wished he could have had more as
he was dominating in that benoni after
being sharper than his opponent but hey
Wesley you've managed to defend it so
kudos to him
yes we are that's what I was gonna say
the players are definitely practicing
their Ruby Lopez skills as we see it yet
again a different variation this time
what I tend to call the Rubinstein rule
elope has with the slow d2 d3 normally
that's on move six normally on mu six
everybody has played a rookie one for
the better part of a hundred years but
d2 d3 was an old idea of Kiba Rubin
steam to slow played the position
threatening to capture the night that
provokes the early b5 and a-two a-three
now Dingle Erin mvl Fabi couple of
others have been trying the slow
variation and the immediate Bishop e6 by
Wesley Wesley saying hey I don't believe
you've got anything I'm just gonna
protect the deep v square we saw a trade
and 92 now as far as I know this is all
pretty much the theory I mean but the
question is does it lead anywhere for
white well catching us up to the current
position what and we have it III so you
don't mind the move d4 because it's
positionally bad exactly you want to
provoke d4 one of the things that I
think white would prefer to avoid is
some line where somehow you know the c5
and Knight d4 gets played in one one way
or another either 94 immediately or
what-have-you
so the
idea of Bishop III is like oh please
please played the move d4 and deny
yourself an opportunity in the future
now it doesn't mean that necessarily
black is busted because he's made a
strategic howler playing d54 it just
it's just a way of trying to take an
option away from this opponent Wesley
after the move Bishop III by the way
just played rook f7 looks like rook d1
got played the rooks doubled and c2 c3
so basically solve the chest so far
nothing much to say rook takes f3
Maurice no you love those exchanged
sacrifices don't see the follow up is
the problem rook F 3 looks I love he
says you know I love to sacrifice pieces
and unbalanced musician material
imbalance is my favorite kind of themes
in chess but I also like to have active
pieces to follow behind that exactly and
just sacrificing and saying well I'm
gonna sit on this position is not my cup
of tea we do see d4 was played by Wesley
attacking that Bishop there it's a very
consequential decision to be sure in
this position I think if you don't play
d4 maybe white is trying to play d4 if
you look at the moves at white plain
work d1 and I was a little scared for
black that have white gets in d4 that
could be very promising position so
poison not just in a tacky move but also
potentially a defensive and friendly
humanity I agree funnily enough I
thought that the bishop should step back
right away the reason I didn't like c3
takes d4 is because I think that Larry's
just mentioned you like sacrificing but
you like pieces to to come charging
right behind and I was thinking that by
trading pawns on d4 you are giving black
an active night suddenly with this movie
5
yeah but how four comes and yes three
any
and let's see how I went down as I was I
was not expecting that but with that eat
oh we did see we're open all of a sudden
what maurice was worried about earlier
there's no way to get pieces in now if
we're caught up in the current position
you'll see that 95 is is the plan
exactly the key to the idea was to take
with the night on this square this was
this whole point Knight takes d4 because
once you eliminate the dark square
Bishop now your pieces do stream you get
the bishop in the game as well the night
definitely to e5 and the bishop
appearing in the game so this sacrifice
totally different story
beautifully done Knight takes d4
knocking out the bishop from the
protection of the dark squares and this
is what you call compensation the main
reason being that whites rooks cannot
gain that easy activity to prove
themselves that yeah I am of actually up
in exchange I'm going to show you what
an exchange feels like not in this
position because the rook on c1 won't
really go anywhere after the move
c5 here we see Queen f4 plate a bishop
can get on that long diagonal the knight
can get to e5 black has more than enough
compensation what amazing beautiful idea
by Wesley yeah I mean everybody who has
ever played a French defense and they
played f6 and f6 takes e5 they're
looking at rook on f8 takes f3 and
anybody who's ever played a Sicilian
open Sicilian with their rook on it from
c8 and sacrifice and rook for an
exchange on c3 so this is a very very
thematic exchange sacrifice by Wesley I
I for one am very surprised that a be
allowed it frankly one just plays with
the you don't 95 in this move what
happens if we just take on at three we
don't trade Queen we don't want to treat
Queens I'm sorry
no you're not getting away with that
forget it I'll stop I'll stop five but
95 there's night 85 right so we have to
play something to stop night age 5 what
Queen h4 h4 there's a good GG six is a
good move just just to put the kibosh on
the night h5 Queen h4 I'd be a little
reluctant because I really like Knight
to e5 Knight takes f3 Bishop d6 somehow
that Queen on f4 is gorgeous and I'm
thinking g7 g6 might be my first choice
that's the move that was played yes not
a one move threat you stop the threat
what else you have you're not gonna play
Knight Age 590 try ground because of
Queen h4 so you had you had your one
move threat and that's it now the knight
has dropped back to f1 just to show you
how anemic it became after that move g6
it was completely dominated by blacks
pieces and now black is for choice
however you look at this position I'd
love to play 95 I mean that's my first
one of course
2019 and and look for the f3 square of
course the knight is headed to d2 right
now here the thing is that I would not
want to do I wouldn't want to release
the pressure that I feel that black has
placed on his opponent Knight takes f3
trade everything hey wait a minute I'm
in an ending where I only have one pawn
for the exchange no way that's no I'm
not giving you that in a dream world I
would love to play Bishop b4 and take on
d2 and then take on f3 and I'm thinking
ok just go ahead and slow play it you've
got you've got an exchange are you gonna
put your rook on g3 well I'll harass you
ha and on a good day I might go Bishop
da to a5 to takes d2 or just play c5 and
d3 so I really like blacks compensation
yes in the worst position you just put
on the board note at blacks pieces
compared to mrs. white exactly all on
the first and second rank like your your
upper one who cares what you're up in
exchange all your pieces are defense
although black pieces are active and
until you start making moves that open
files and give you chances we don't care
this is clear compensation and I and
I'll say you know we wanted to sack on
f3 oh sure but the point was how to
follow it up it's Wesley with the genius
idea of the way he played it playing
with nine takes on d4 that was the sweet
one and he showed how it's done and now
we have this position on the board and
he's played the move Queen back to eight
six attacking the rook well he played
first Bishop to d6 he didn't play the
move Knight e5 which I've been kind of
pounding the table get the Knight to e5
he first played Queen afore now he's
just said look I just set up the bishop
on d6 and only after roof g3 did he drop
back with this Queen say look I'm
eyeballing you rook are you really gonna
let me take it well i'ma tell you
straight on if you wanted my rook in
this position you can have yeah right
he's point and he's played Knight
to who how ironic that I wanted to play
with the knight on e5 I wanted to give
up the the bishop for the night how
ironic that he could play now Bishop f4
followed by Knight e5 c5 and then he
could take the knight whenever he wants
that's a nice that's a nice variation
but we do have Knight d2 on the board I
wanted to say as as fabbi is saying hey
look your compensation is so good I'm
gonna give you back the exchange what
happens after takes by the way and more
is your question and asked on the board
that my Wesley shaking his head
vigorously right now as though he missed
something but he looks what is nested
like what he people shake their head you
know even if they think their position
is good I notice that with he card up
sometimes it's not always a direct oh
like in poker
for instance when somebody acts upset
usually they have a good hand and the
opposite
yeah this is chess and I don't know
would want to act this way when his
position he's gotten the exchange back
this is an exchange I'm happy to give
back if I'm white I'm not sure I'd like
to see a queen just posting on e3 the
way this going would you would want to
see but it looks like the deep on could
come under fire them this one here's the
money now like Bobby's playing a Benoni
again right before the pawn structure is
shifted that way and the deep on once
again is weak well here's the problem
White's facing it's a very concrete
problem if you defend the Queen which is
Diane you're just allowing this night to
for kir pawns and basically if you play
f4 well there goes your pawn so he could
just win upon after rook e1 and he's
done it
yep is that right I mean are at that
point where it looks to me like it's
pretty much game over
e5 I mean the max I'm the pawn grubber
this looks like a very very handsome
extra pond here for black because you
also have the better better rook in
mitternight
so it's not just a pawn exactly it's not
waste what just happened what just
happened looks like this is good moves
this was good I think Wesley just played
after night b3 c5 defending his pawn
now after rook t2 he didn't want to play
c4 right away because of Knight takes d4
so he played a v inviting this but after
he fought okay here let me see what what
did he play after c5 rookie two and then
and he played c4 right Knight takes d4
again he's far back and then Aoife man
Aoife
okay so he did do it this way I wasn't
sure what order Wesley did this so now
he's he's given back the pawn after F
takes e5 so rook check rook here that
looks pretty good
rook check rook e1 I like both I don't
know which is best i I definitely like
the check and I like going after this
bond and I equally like going after this
pawn as well I just don't know which is
the best pawn to go after my inclination
would be to go after the b-pawn because
if I can win b2 then the pawn on c4
should should be enough for a win what
is Wesley thinking about here what's the
alternative he can jack and take on
before No
well is it White's did why looks like he
has taken I'm not up to date right now
and my board is this the guy my last
move I see his F takes e5 right right it
is it is blocks Lee to play and Wesley I
think should play rook f1 if I'm playing
a blitz game I'm thinking check and r1
because I'm thinking if I could take
this guy then this pawn and in the
meanwhile if I can get a knight ending
these two pawns on e5 and E 4 aren't
going anywhere
how's this what about b3 though in that
exact position when you play like this
exact position yeah yes because you
don't and so a take upon and I'll take
it if to rook have to be careful and
I'll trade rooks it's the night ending
that I want I'm trying to play a knight
ending with a queen sight majority away
from the cake
I don't know Wesley's taking a lot of
time what else could he be imagining hmm
not sure he's deep he spent a long time
and he's shaking his head now as you can
see he does not he's not satisfied with
whatever variations he's coming up with
at the moment he knew he had a fantastic
position or he knows now that he had a
fantastic position and now he's feeling
again like what the heck
where's the where's the out where's the
one of these talks like look we do have
a position on the board we do have the
position it looks like we need to catch
up with the players we do have this
position with rook to F at the end of
the position yeah this is the same
position we were looking for but look
Knight you've got a trade rooks now
because Knight d6 well you can wait one
tempo but you can't wait to these days
is coming and that's at least a draw in
there you're gonna to play h5 to stop
the purple actually h6
might be more prudent because h5 there
might be an H for burial in there
somewhere this position is no longer
easily winning you're going to looks
like have to go for rugby to trade off
pieces but yes sir even though you're
talking about that night ending with the
outside passer is that an easy one no
I'm not saying it's easy I'd saying it's
advantage black and the exploit was to
be - yeah I'm thinking that we're in
that moment where he you really spent a
lot of time that moved 30 - I was
thinking that maybe I should have just
gone for the night ending directly with
the move rook F - and in this case
played with three versus two on the
Queen side definitely better in my view
for black but okay what we do have is a
very tricky ending in front of us now
ninety six on the board and Wesley
saying I'm gonna pick off one of your
pawns with ninety seven how do you stop
that and if you do stop that then I'm
going to bring my King into the game as
well I do
my own Trump's hold on so we're
consequentially 94 right 97 gif made
upon take and now I want to you're gonna
get one but you're not gonna get both
cuz I play nice see five so if I play
King F no I'm gonna play King in to the
game king of King into the gonna know
not there because you have an ID for
check I don't want to face I gotcha
mm-hmm here and now 95 now 95 Knight d4
trying to go okay if I go one more over
you're not you're promoting so I can
just play Knight to stop you right
Knight to stop me and okay and you know
I shouldn't got eight forward for a
while yeah I've tied you down but no I
understand I can right we're in the game
or anything with the active King so
that's a difference and then it looks
and look at the way they have gone and
they're similar that white king is just
too good that white king is fast it's
fast it comes into the game to help
against the beep on the knight by itself
cannot do the job so it looks like this
is very going very quickly to a draw
Wesley disappointed in himself as this
position looked so promising at one
moment after his exchange sacrifice but
he was not able to find just the right
moves you see him already I don't know
where he's looking like you looking out
the window somewhere saying come on what
does it take to beat this guy I had a
great position very promising but was
not able to seal the deal with the
accurate moves as Fabiano now also with
an edge on the clock
not a big edge still Stella you gotta
save blacks a little bit better in this
knighting Knight endings can be very
tricky I just want to say okay so we
just seem to move King III I was
expecting Knight III by the way so why
aren't we a saying Knight c5 here for
yes sir
yeah yeah I mean how does your King even
do anything here I'm talking about the
black King because II 5 shuts you down
completely which he is what he's done by
the way e5 King f7
came back to d2 it's kind of like a
mutual standoff I can't go with a king
be6
and I can't go with a king to b3 and I
can't give it a 7 because a knight c6
check right Keaney 796 check we're kind
of boxed out there exactly now this is
looking I'd be very surprised as you
said they're tricky endings but I'd be
very surprised if this is anything but a
drawn we've jumped ahead as they made
many MOOCs and last one we're convinced
hands because of that 60 move draw so
they're gonna probably find a way to
Peter or just play 10 more moves so what
happened is they did play that line by
the way with King e7 Knight check what
you are saying Jim and they quickly got
to two versus two done deal
draw agreed is because there is a 60
move rule you know that I saw in the
regulations they only made it to move 49
of course this is dead drawn and they
can offer each other a draw but I think
in the previous game too that rook
ending they didn't exactly make it to 60
and there wasn't a reputation it was a
draw agreed I mean clearly it's a drug
and clearly of course the rules do state
that you stipulate that it's 60 moves
not anything less never less a an
opportunity going now into the clutch
games we find the score Fabi with the
one-point lead but we've had three draws
so far nip and tuck action mistakes
getting made but still this is the
situation two and a half to one and and
that's right we're gonna have one have a
lot more blood could have been filled in
this match
every game easily it could have been
miss I said and we are going to start
those clutch beams that's coming up
right after two points for the win a
draw for 1.2 K instant bonus for any
game that you win and that money is in
addition to the overall prize pool so
you've got 30 K for first 20 K for the
runner-up well the big clutch money at
stake today games 5 in 6 2 K for him
clutch games 11 in 12 it's 7 K and if
there are draws today even more money
will go into those final games
I predict that games 11 and 12 will
feature at least $8,000 a game as I
think one of those games will be drawn
to game 5 or game 6 I don't see blood
being spilled in both games that would
be wild in the action but we'll see as
the games will commence soon we're gonna
take a break we'll be right back
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
[Music]
we're people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's a bra here
being here and really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we are back with clutch chess as we
are in the collection of the competition
these next two games will be work a
double points a win will get two points
that means if Fabiano wins she's gonna
extend his lead to three point lead
while if Wesley wins will actually be
prog Bobby and take a one-point lead
so much at stake including a 2k instant
bonus
well this finals has given us the type
of chess we expected at the top of the
show both players in top-notch form that
both players also missing opportunities
and after having played beautifully like
that Benoni game that fabbi played was a
great game he uncorked his beautiful
sacrifice and then he played very badly
allowing Wesley an opportunity to f4 and
it was a case of mutual double blindness
so although we've seen a lot of draws
we've been seeing great fighting
fighting draws and what I would
determine and now with these clutch
chess games and two points up for grabs
okay
somebody's got to rise to the occasion
and we're back to 1g that water
increased No yeah has increased and we
see Wesley essaying
what he played against Nakamura right
Bishop g5 will he play eight six Bishop
f4 again this is that would be amazing
baby blade it worked it worked like a
charm against ícaro absolute charm a
blistering victory with the white pieces
against a car well that's that rook d7
game we're talking about and we do see
him playing the exact same idea but Fabi
he's done his homework one of the best
don't want it so I'm thinking I'll see
four right now thank you very much we're
not going for that other line playing
I'm playing a 4/4 all in d4 for a win it
really depends on the ins and outs of
your repertoire but it interests me that
Wesley is tossing out d4 for these
clutch games he thinks this is the way
to go for clearly yes and yeah and by
the way he's doing it and the kind of
variation
that Fabi prepared heavily for against
magnus carlsen in their World
Championship match in 2018 you remember
those Rock'em Sock'em battles that
happens in that match and with with
Magnus playing d4 and Fabia saying the
Queens gambit declined so right boldly
stepping into what must be great
preparation by Fabiano Carwin and we see
this move III a six on the board trend
offering a transposition of sorts to a
Queens gambit accepted which is well and
that B's repertoire actually in Wesley's
as well and the difference is that
normally in a Queens gambit accepted
White's Bishop is actually on c1 in this
particular case it's on the far more
active f4 square so I have to say
advantage white once again and the
openings using some quickness by the way
right yes if you really jump back let me
go back to what happened here first of
all that we did CH 6 it takes and now a
6 and the players quickly are playing a
kind of a Queens gambit accepted with
Knight e5 and trades and I'm up to date
with the players now after Bishop takes
e5 again slight advantage for white
normally in a Queens gambit accepted
black has to get in the move c5 followed
by c5 takes d4 in order to equalize so
he's a move or two away from achieving
that here three we should all rate at
all mr. might suggest itself what it has
been played what have you trained 45
what's wrong well then I take on c5 if
you take find it and then rook d1
followed by Bishop f6 and it's a clear
advantage
Wesley what Oh could you picture yeah
just to be clear
Bishop a3 queen of three c5 takes on c5
here after takes rook d1 if you play
Queen e7 takes followed by Knight e4
advantage Wesley so but when you play
taste I can't play Queen takes
may what I wanted to say is maybe after
Queen takes you gotta throw in 97 and
this looks this looks like what fabbi
did is he did throw in 97 yep and have
397 I very important move c5 play now c5
yes and when big block gets this move in
if you don't have anything as white that
punishes black shows some real
positional bind this usually just leads
to equalizing position and equality
right the only move to deeply consider
in my opinion is to move d5 exactly
which is 85 that's easy that's easy
chess ya know that I would note nobody
disputes that that is a line but now
with the move d5 you can create an
imbalance at least of four versus three
on the kingside three versus two on the
Queen side and you've got a knight and
you're a little bit behead a free of
pieces your queen is already on that
three the queen is still on d8 so d5 but
I'm sure Wesley is trying to argue if I
play rook d1 and if you take and I take
with the rook am i I have an advantage
how big is my advantage just didn't
happen by the way he did play d5 capture
on d5 Knight takes and the knight to f6
on the board saying let's go for this
imbalance which are you be suitable
giving black the three to two on the
Queen side if you will looks like you've
got you already gave him the three to
two actually well here the the question
is night c7 what 97 am I getting back
your Knights going back to d5 in a
second right crook there's a rook a 7d
one of the Queen C a queen that's right
okay so 95 or Queen c6 whoa we're going
in with c6 by the way instead of 27 or
play 97 we just saw after night as rip
d1 you
one 1985 Rick tasty five so
unfortunately this feels too easy from
blackmail Queen b6 I think we're fabbi
is going to be happy with the outcome
suddenly the Queen on b6 yeah followed
by c4 yeah he's done it Queen b6 rook d2
d1 rook to d8 and I think that once
fatty plays c5c for any fears of past
what about playing work to b7 in this
position is that gonna help at all where
you're gonna stick your [ __ ] up I'm
probably playing Queen e6 just Queen e6
yeah I'm probably doing that but but
maybe just rating yeah well trading will
keep in mind work on d1 you're not
threatening rookie 7 sorry just like
that this does not contain this threat
because of route oopsy-daisy there's
something at the end of the line here
that actually gangs the a2 pond
yeah for example so this this looks like
zero now the white and white better be
careful because there yes the only
advantage in this position looks like
the 3 to 2 he should draw but you know I
this is old-school kappa blanka right
getting that majority back back in the
old days they used to think this was
almost automatically winning for black
yeah better for black
that was the old thing but the Queen
side majority was too powerful here I'm
thinking that if I'm in Wesley shoes I
started thinking defensive-minded lee
with the bishop coming to e5 not just to
attack but rather to kind of constrain
or control this c5 b for c3 passer
action so something like Bishop e5 he
put h3 my boat you play h3 or b3 he
played beefy he played h3 first trade of
rooks and then after rook da rook d8 he
played b3 now he's played v3
look with it with the rooks off it's
looking a lot closer complete
neutralization by Fabi in this opening
very quickly and by the way so quickly
that they've they've used what less than
three minutes
barely to how little over two minutes
this game has proceeded at such a quick
pace that it could be over in 10 yeah
and again we yesterday in the
semi-finals we kept seeing linear didn't
Dominguez being behind four minutes you
know each game and suddenly like fab me
was winning the drawn positions he was
he was saving the the good the bad
position so not being behind on the
clock either player really playing very
very fast and one point lead a one-point
lead for Cara wanna in the match we know
that slim a slimmest of margins in such
a match of course Wesley though a little
too perturbed because he could be tied
right now yesterday though he was down
one after six game so he can certainly
make a big comeback but five years
playing awfully well and getting good
opening positions while he's at it so
definitely Wesley has to be a little bit
careful and I again there we go Fabi has
gotten the move c4 in right not the end
of the world that's to be sure but it's
black who's got to pass pawn sitting in
the position so be careful no question
about it the most dangerous pawn in the
position is this criminal sitting on c4
but I'm playing Bishop e5 Bishop but I'm
late for a threat isn't there right on
the back rank Queen B one checking h2
yeah and then what
trade rookie he has by the way played
Bishop mine what's in here take take
Queen check King up Queen takes what is
you would like to take this pawn rook
takes d5 firsts get on I see sorry
65 first Queen takes the ride
go ahead and check and now take me I'll
take 182 okay so I'm one genic going
after this guy let's go after this guy
right okay
I've checked okay hide it
Bishop back for example you do have a
queen CA and I'm gonna create two
threats right I want to either take the
pawn on c4 or play Bishop d6 okay that
is for CH that is okay you but even here
- it looks like yeah you got away with
that one but even here white black does
have a past a pawn on occasion black is
still for choice yeah black you play
Queen a3 Queen a3 give you the C pawn
push the a pawn as far as you can and
see what happens yeah your no question
you're better no question you're better
with that passed pawn oops excuse me I
don't want to hit the keyboard there my
dad okay he did not play that way he
decided to just trade and so she 586 14
Buddha's yay trade he did not go for
that line how interesting he could have
gone check and taken the pond was there
it was there an alternative here for
white that I missed
maybe maybe fabbi saw something maybe
check and check maybe this is what this
disturb him that's a problem
good point that'll do it you don't want
to play g6 here for any good reason
because it could lead to some back rank
dangerous for sure yes that is a good
point
alright well we're in a sharp ending
that that looks like white should have
enough compensation with these Queen
endings they're all about passed pawns
and King security that's it that's what
they bought down to one person has seen
security in one person as a past five
that's right I mean this is all about
class pawns and King security how strong
is your pastor can you make it work and
how
how exposes your king can I make you
suffer while you're trying to get pawns
on the board if anybody is trying for
the win here it is black-white has
difficulty getting any movement but he
has great chances against that King
that's a bit exposed for sure especially
thanks to the fractured double pawns
it means that whenever black plays the
move King g7 to cover this pawn there's
a check and you regret the fact that you
have the double pawns so I'm thinking
that this is really like super close to
a draw I mean I don't like for example
go ahead if I play a move like f3 and
just say do your worst
by the way e4 was play it has even more
oppressive more direct take my design
please and drop your babies on the Kings
side know what I'm gonna happen he's
gonna looks like yesterday's star ting
to look like a draw and we should point
out a draw in this game takes the $2,000
from game 5 and puts it on games 11 and
12 already worth 7 grand each will then
be worth $8,000
right and we do have the draw happening
but in front of us they have decided to
go for the draw and that is what will
occur oh hi game 5 now looking like it's
in the books right or has it happened
yet they're still sitting there so hard
to believe that that it's over okay I
don't think it's doing continue to sit
no I mean from where that's the look
that's the look of relief and they're
they're going yeah I was about to say I
you know Wesley is just taking a glance
to see well like could I go here take
this pawn and run my age pawn no no and
no this pawn is way too fast
better to take the perpetual and play
the last clutch game of the
first half the Mack and like we said the
bonus now rolling over to the finals
final two games making them even more
important and I believe it was you yeah
who said I don't think this match is not
is going to be decided before the finals
the final final two games this is going
the distance and we could tell in the
final game
I agree the final game is a very final
game that game is going to count so much
with a draws the proliferation of draws
in this match game 11 might be a draw
and we could see a lot of cash pushing
over to game 12 with everything on the
line and by the way we should point out
the tight breaks could come into effect
as well if they don't win the clutch
game anybody wins any clutch games and
the score is tied at the end we're on to
a tie-break we're on to the tiebreak the
clutch money is out the window they
would not have been able to win it and
it would be all down to the tiebreaks to
decide but that would require Wesley
winning a game and evening up this match
which isn't which is not impossible
obviously just needs to with 1 out of
the 4 remaining single point games in
order to tie up the match but so much
will ride on those games and also of
course the clutch games which award so
many points and we're gonna take a short
break anyway we'll have our final game
yes it is a clutch game worth double
points right after the break
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever that we stay connected to
carry on that mission we are currently
offering 24 weekly classes online
through our YouTube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home students can enjoy all
the benefits of our scholastic chess
initiative digital our Scholastic
outreach continues with virtual chess
classrooms scholastic tournaments and
scouts BSA merit badge workshops on
behalf of everyone at the st. Louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play enjoy the game of chess st. Louis
University celebrating its 200th
anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the same Lewis Chess
Club to start a top-tier collegiate
chest tube on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best University at the pan-american
intercollegiate Chess Championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we are back with clutch chest and
our final cuts game it's Wesley Silver's
Fabiano Kurata the winner will be the
leader going in tomorrow into tomorrow
it'll either be Bobby by three points or
Bradley by one point it could be a draw
guys I don't know I'm smelling blood in
the water what do you think well I mean
we've been seeing some tremendous chest
as far as the players get ready for this
all-important Game six just one of them
the players have played so fast
it's been hard for us to analyze and and
point out and I just was saying on our
break that I think there was a missed
opportunity in clutch game number one
that is the game five
Wesley quickly it played on move 14
Bishop - gee miss Shipp - g3 instead I
think many grandmasters especially
Wesley being a Catalan player in the
Catalan you're always trying to play
that move c7 c5 and cattle and players
just love to post up on the c6 square
I'm not saying that Wesley has an
overwhelming advantage or anything like
that it's just the move that you play in
these types of positions to stop c5 do
we have a game anyway let's all go in
we're back in the real apes' argument
yes so far Wesley's remembering that
good deal you had that great exchange
sacrifice and Fabio he walks right into
the position one hand time does he end
that I would think he has any proven he
doesn't want to see that rook f3
sacrifice again counts his lucky stars
that he was able to draw that position
Wesley Wright broke we weren't happy to
see Wesley take that rook on g3 even
though he had what's supposed to be a
great position but giving away his
bishop for that rook on g3 didn't seem
quite right and now Fabi has changed
tactics and played the move a four right
before in the previous game he played
Bishop III trying to in to induce the
move D 54 but a4 is his improvement
yes now question by the way is it an
improvement by the way if this game is
drawn then games 11 and 12 tomorrow will
be worth nine thousand dollars each
right and that's pretty pretty tense
a lot of money and just two of the most
tense games in the match and it's
looking more and more like that is
guaranteed to happen unless somebody
runs away with it in the morning
tomorrow which doesn't look like it
should be the guess happen no they're
just so resourceful and so tightly mad
it just seems that inevitably some of
the games are drawn right to put on you
know three in a row
yes Wow Leon like that Leslie's doubled
rooks again again and once again
Fabiano is saying look I don't believe
in the sacrifice and he's just said
prove it I played the move rook on a1 to
e1 do you want to sacrifice and let's
just have a quick gander at this rook
thanks f3 G takes f three the last time
you saw a line where the knight jumped
to d4 and the knight was gonna go to e5
and black was exploiting the dark
squares in this particular case yeah now
we can understand why yeah why
fabbi would say hey I don't believe in
the sacrifice because Knight d4 but even
so I'm still a little bit partial to the
sacrifice frankly I'm thinking okay let
me play a move like Bishop here trying
to get some dark square control what are
the rooks actually doing Queen c5 played
by the way Queen c5 and Queen eight to
d1 Queen c5 yes Queen d1 I'm not sure
what is so attractive in fabi's mind
about thank you g3 has been the knight
on f3 is not going anywhere all squares
covered it's a-okay right now he is
threatening or looks like he's
threatening the e pawn yes
so okay I guess I was wrong mmm well
what do you you think you should take
the pawn on e4
no yeah but what happens after takes on
d5 now what am I missing
oh he played Queen b6 sorry I missed and
five and then take back on d5 and Knight
takes keep taking stuff and you're
you're not worried about f2 at the end
of the day in this position I guess I do
have to worry about it I would be forced
I don't want to play Knight H 1 which is
2 by the way sorry am I missing
something
III think I calculated I counted wrong
I'm sorry I can just yeah that's right
away that's easy
yeah my apologies as well that's
obviously the case no way you can take
for that and you can take that pawn all
right there you go so now what in this
position whoa for blowing open the
center of the board with his rook with
his knight on f3 also intake by the way
that's still a possibility but white
feels like he's much better prepared in
this position than he was before to play
for a lot of this exchange sacrifice
what a move look at that central
formation Wow I I'm not sure I believe
it do you guys believe it it's on the
board and it looks like a capture of
pawn takes on d4 pawn takes on d5 takes
and we now have this position on the
board like Wesley feeling like he should
be okay in this K well well I'm thinking
if you take the pawn back with Knight
xt4 there is this move Bishop c5
eyeballing the whoa
eyeballing f2 I guess you have to play
rook e61 good pin deserves another
exactly exactly so Bishop d4
Bishop D for queen bee for xe6 and at
the end of the day what is going how do
we well I feel like the entire DC pond
might be more valuable than the athan
that's that's that's a nice judgment Jen
I agree with you that when whites come
up roses
instead of recapturing why displayed
rookie six talking about upping the ante
in a clutch game this is the we came to
see what a move rookie six coming down
at the moment but what's actually
happening as the knight on c6 finds
itself pinned you you want to be very
careful by the way because forecast
three and ninety five but he just played
95 right away yeah I was about to say 95
attacking the rook the rook f3
what was your intended follow-up did you
want a 1995 going on fight gen this pawn
that was a sharp line as they work c6
and 95 is the possibility here right so
we have and what's wrong with rook c6
that does look like a possibility or
what's wrong with the simple Bishop
takes talk about pinning down the guys
Knights now suddenly he has played this
and neither one of blacks Knights can
move without the pain of the Queen
dropping you don't see this every day
two nights pinned in two different
pieces against a queen this is
fascinating stuff on the board right now
what to play in this position he might
need to unpin he's got to unpin somebody
any play Bishop to d6 opening at c6
Knight that is now ready to take the
bishop on III drop that Bishop dropping
back probably to the III square will
have to drop back right so 94 now and
then c6 so 94 is your other expecting
Knight takes d4 is the threat followed
by Knight takes c6 no question
see five there's Queen takes e5 and yeah
that defends the pawn on d5 very nicely
do so you could find that you want to
play Bishop III sorry yes Maurice I want
to play Knight g5 it feels like a
blunder but I just want to play it okay
let's have a looksie Knight g5 so you're
eyeballing op eyeball in Queen h5 as
well as Knight f7 so Knight takes d4 do
you have a cruncher Rou I was right that
was my idea
but right it looks like he can just stop
me by h6g six and then oh you can buy g6
and then play for rook g7 and I don't
have any continuation that I shut it all
down so now no tactics there to look at
as yes this one g7 shutting everything
down nice okay he played solidly with
the move Bishop back to e3 that was the
expected one Square back Bishop to e3
and now the move Knight d8 whoa whoa
contortionist tightening to try to get
at this rook that has nowhere to go
what's up well is there let's say 95
potentially five what you could think
about it although route takes up three
would be look at this chaos did you see
did you see maybe he wants to play d5
Jack work takes d5 maybe instead of he
takes the Queen takes d5 check runs in
mission c5 Bishop c5 is is easy no you
don't know Intermezzo no mr. Bishop c5
would have done it because you didn't
you do a fruit d5 in the position as we
analyze their queen c g5 and then that's
fine
and now rook h5 wait a second count them
black is black is not any material no no
no it's even see it's even Stephen still
night that night g5 idea is coming back
in the mix so night to e6 stopping that
is that rook on h5 a useful piece or is
it a bad piece on that square because
there's no coordination is a miss
coordination for the moment in whites
camp with that rook on h5 you want to
use it but how how do you get it there
well how about 94 try to remove then I
don't need six and get that Queen into
the game somehow well I hate being in
this fan grandma night 84 what night
night a lack of coordination on the even
more even more I mean the night go to
age for you say wait is this organized
and by the way where's that rook going
looks really bad what about night after
for now
what about Knight f4 just trying I would
trade everything off in that case look
g6 on the board now that kind of move
you've got terrified of how do your your
rook looks really really bad it is
isolated beast over there not
coordinating with your pieces whatsoever
and how does he what does he do rook
eight six you feel like your gauge you
can feel the rook is is gonna just be in
trouble Bishop f4 you have to trade and
and after the knight takes the rook is
just you're just down a rook the Kings
right oh man Bobby's getting outplayed
at the moment this looks terrible for
white team look at the organization of
blacks forces blacks forces are all
together the rooks Knights business -
just this is one little pin that white
has but otherwise whites rook on f1 is
not in play the night
g3 can't get in the game the rook is
hanging on h4 sacrificed on g6 90s GC
Wow
Queen to g4 how about seven Bishop e6
pawn takes h5 my knight is protecting
you Network on g7
no no that's busted that's over you
can't do that so work g7 what do you do
you gotta move your like these guys
he's gotta move out of work again and
every 27 work h6 was played exactly
going after the sensitive button on g6
but this is really hard to believe I'm
like no I'm I'm very very skeptical
you're only getting two pawns for the
rook in this position there will be some
hustle factor that will come into this
one but that's about it you're getting
but it looks like you're getting your
second pawn don't forget there is a
there is a little there's a there's a
little Queen and he's play Queen c7
smart move there's a little Queen h4
action or Queen h3 maybe h4 is better
trying to get trying to flush that King
out into the game but Queen c7
level-headed don't play it now as rook
h7 will probably land on the board and
you're well then again the g6 pawn is
hanging what are you what are we
thinking about they're not worried about
Paige for let's say Queen h4 and I say
go ahead finish your threat right yeah
cause Rick 87 is not really doing
anything at the king f7 I made an get
uuuu flush my king to f7 but that's
basically no your queen oc7 came back
right on time that's good that's good
yeah well he took on g6 Wesley has
played the move what what happened he
took on g6 and Wesley traded how did you
get the bushes 53 HT 3 I've got the
Knights but the Knights got traded how
did we get here he took on c5 he took on
c5 oh he
his dark squared bishop and then took on
a sense that was where we saw this trade
on g3 and now we're expecting this night
to post up gorgeous center mostly well
two ponds two ponds and maybe a third if
he can pick off the pawn on b4 and
Wesley said having it just a five
freezing that side completely this looks
like not enough compensation inviting a
trade if I'm white I'm trying to keep
the attack alive but you did really more
okey one lucky one trying to keep now
everybody wants to play ninety-four
really and I understand that move very
much so but you just have to be aware
that there is a queen a six check no
Queen of seven-inch you play Queen f7
attacking the rook and and causing trade
right to trade and so we have a pair of
force the trade and this end game looks
so bad we do see three passed pawns one
of them a pair of them doubled but that
night is gonna come in the game and I
would be scared
I mean I'm I think it's over yeah I
think and I'm busted in there right the
worst thing is after Queen trade if you
go Queen trade King takes f3 you're
thinking to yourself you know like hey I
got this night out of the game no no no
no no this is this is for verses three
and these three connected pawns on g2 g3
are not that powerful the King actually
is a great defender and you could just
imagine that black is easily going to
whip on I'm not scaring anybody exactly
not in this position you it's gonna be
hard for you to move them without losing
them in fact that's that's that's not
what I signed up for but what else are
we supposed to do because
it's coming in to e4 next yes like if
you move your queen the knight is a
headed to e4 and then f2 is gonna be
tender Roni you can't play f3 because
you're hanging g3 and what play do you
have that's a Bobby is in big trouble
and he's down 2 minutes on the clock as
well he's played the move Queen h3
that's not what you want to do that was
for sure
no and 94 is just again now it really
begs to be played because in this case
is also its queen e6 check sorry how
about Queen Oh Siamese Queen f7 Queen g4
horse queen or even 7 upon it it's is
that so clear Queen e6 check if you know
it's there's a queen g4 problem right
and look at these guys what Bobby play
Queen h3 and Wesley play Queen h8 that's
a pretty any cream king rock on the back
row like that was it super being get it
green so Fisher and anybody what why did
he play Queen h8 yeah well check happen
they put me right back on g7 those were
in buying that weird maneuver no way are
you mad no that was white I would be
elated with a draw I'd run I'd run out
say thank you very much
I don't want to analyze yeah so you'd
give away your firstborn child that you
don't have no way in the world that
Bobby Knight Lord and Queenie seguida
Shaq and this is a chance he's hoping
for is this king to expose four-block to
land a killer blow okay let's go through
the variation for just a second suppose
we go Queen f7 now again don't even
think about touching the c6 bone Queen
FF - we've got Queen g4 and let's say we
move our king eventually you're gonna
have to block with the Queen though with
more checks right is there some f3
business that Wesley could be afraid of
yes exactly if if you check me a couple
of times I'm gonna block with my queen
we're going in into this
oh no you play King h7 right away my
pleasure King h7 and if you check again
he can get his Queen to 86 and then back
his king up two and then back his king
up to h8 right Queen HK check here can
be met by Queen 86 right so he did not
play Queen f7 he played only play King
Asia so check right away could be met by
this right no we could check banking
back what's your nice right
I I ran out of checks that's what we
that's why we told the landlord when he
came for the rent but this position
looks winning well it's the game
it's the game we're looking at it King
h8 looks like you won't get another
check and night f2 and Queen h1 is mate
mm-hmm exactly
Knight f2 Queen h1 that's easy peasy and
you also cannot play rook f1 because it
looks like can't you just take on f2
anyway night of 2 over 19 million
Queenie
yeah I like night g3 I think that's
pretty convincing actually he seems
because you've got that that made on h1
is this a knight who is the same night
of 2 wins the material the same way
both moves when and if we're seeing that
you know Wesley C is it yes
his only it turns out now as Fabi is
just regretting this position completely
is the Move f3 what else can you do
right let's say he has a move now but
what else can you do
sorry so you're kind of three the idea
is that after Queen d2 you start getting
your checks again with clean age three
track that's the hope that's just no I
don't believe it either but I'm just
saying you got to try something right
yeah wait rookies or be careful rookie 4
is a mistake I'm a Queen d2 is a mistake
because all right right yeah Ricky I
think the room oh okay so this is the
current position again just to remind
everybody Wesley so he's trailing by a
point that this clutch game has two
points at stake so should Wesley win
this game he'll actually take a lead
going into tomorrow's finals he will
also eliminate any tie breaks any time
frame and look at this rookie - and this
is what I was talking about the night of
- tactic night of - is possible just
take night of - and if you take then you
play this check your King has to move
give me a rook and you're not drawing no
prepare no prepared however dad means
losing it by the way that looks like the
exact same move yeah that's the same
point you are not getting out King -
h2o2 will come and it's the same
position you have to play rook takes and
hope you can draw you're not drawing
that position or the the queen or the
rook will come back and take care of
business
did he just repeat moves I don't know
why no I just put the King on h2 it
didn't look like you repeated you wanted
to try maurices move order but it is
normally we talk about how important
move order is but it actually look like
in this case they both line
you see so precise with move order well
is it coat house think like a
grandmaster where you were always
obliged to make a repetition to show
your opponent that you're you're the one
playing for a win I don't agree with
that yes and I think is it you who say
that you don't like that book that
mother is that somebody that was me that
was me
I thought it was a garbage book and it
was like like Lauda din Americas the
amateurs Bible you know you don't like
you don't like nimzowitsch my system Wow
people treasured coming up like a
four-time US Champion and the position
finally 9f2 and rook takes on f2 did
happen after the Queen c1 check rook F
to Queen h3 check and he's hoping that
somehow he's going to be able to swing
the Queen around and get a draw but it's
not to be believed no March either March
to the other side block with a rook or
block with a queen they're three
different things to do and Fabi has that
look of a man who knows he's dead he
used to hire he is in big trouble after
King g7 and this game is busted did he
resign he's about game is over Wesley so
in a clutch game needing to come back
has done it right yeah what you know
what a magnificent depends there's a lot
of these pressure that was on Wesley
even the movie 5 out of the blue it
looks super strong threatening Bishop
takes if I just as his calmness you know
playing c6 96
g6 rebuffed the attack and you know most
people aren't mostly weren't doing that
against Bobby it's easy to collapse yes
it is easy to collapse some very nice
defensive moves but Knight H for that oh
bit of a heads I attention for Miley you
can't believe a knight is one
the h4 and somehow coordinating miss
coordinating your forces and look at
this after day one Wesley so take the
lead with four and a half three and a
half also pocketing a couple of G while
he's added and by winning today's clutch
game he has assured that there is no
reason it is mathematically impossible
were there to be a tie-break match they
are gonna win it in 12 that's what's
gonna happen the next six games will
decide it tomorrow absolutely crucial
now for them to get their heads right
because it's on it's game on
doesn't get much closer than this guys
yeah I did before we go I just want to
point out that that was the that was a
blunder Blue Byte knighted by Fabiana
that night aged four there was an
opportunity for Fabi to maybe get that
three-point lead he could have played
night on g3 to e4 an easy move to miss
because there is what is what happens 84
Queen b6 pawn takes on f f3 yeah you're
gonna play Queen you could just take the
c5 Knight but so what would this is hard
to calculate yeah as I mean there's 10
for 8 and then g2 and all that well we
will talk to the man of the hour man of
the day clutch game victory for Wesley
so Wesley thanks for joining us tell us
how you felt first of all about how the
day went that you were trailing for most
of it I'm not sure Hughes looks like
Wesley is not hearing us at the moment
so we will get him on the line as we're
trying to get the leader in the
tournament at the moment Wesley so that
move that variation you're talking about
yes I mean that's easy to miss that's
the I'm sorry that but I thought I know
that's not even close to winning I mean
that's just a crazy line do I hear that
we maybe we do have Fabiano Caruana on
the line
however Fabi can you hear us I can't
hear you
I'm hearing him speak but i'm not
hearing him in my earpiece you guys I'm
not I'm not hearing Fabi myself so I
won't be bought to the question so I'll
just ask and you have no what what did
you feel about the day you were trailing
for most of it but I'll hiccup at the
end you mean I was I was leading I
that's what I meant leading for most of
it but hiccup at the end yeah no I mean
this last game was very sharp and I lost
control I mean of course what I did is
is extremely risky it's just based on
tactics to play this whole rookie six
rookie five all that stuff but it felt
very dangerous for him then yeah I guess
94 at some moment was was better like
did you just take on spot sorry yeah
this this 94 move I mean this one did
you did you not see it at all I mean
that looks like something crazy even if
you do see it it looks crazy no but I
could do it the previous booth this is
much stronger than here I mean here it
looks yeah here here as much here's the
moment to play 94 instead of rook cage
[Laughter]
585 he has to take only five I think
yeah right it's bishop is on my threat
and then you take on c5 yourself yeah I
haven't my text but I'm not sure that
that works but I can just play Bishop
takes and then Bishop f8 a Bishop c5 I
mean and Queen c7 Bishop f8 take on e4 I
guess 95 and he takes on a theta and we
end up with equal points but my
structure as much as that was a great
opportunity for know I lost control I I
yeah I shouldn't have started sacking
pieces I mean 96 I could have played
work 86 and still remains a complete
mess
although clearly things have gone wrong
but I still I need work age six and I
was thinking he would play Knight at
four but this is this is still a mess I
mean it's not like a knight of four I
still have 94 so so he can't do that so
he has to do something else my autumn
[ __ ] before was what I didn't like
right but in any case I'm not down
material I mean it's not a good position
but I do keep my pieces I can take well
it's still sitting on eight six what did
you feel was the quality of the day's
play obviously both of you missed some
tactics along the way there's that game
where you took on e4 in the Benoni and
looked like - alright you were winning
but you didn't end up winning that game
it looked like also he had a great game
against you when he was up three pawns
are those game one even it seemed like
just wild uncommon uncompromising play
with maybe some errors yeah I think the
quality was maybe not too high but we
were playing very difficult positions he
blundered 94 I think this was clear and
then I was a nice shot I mean precise
yeah this this collects everything I
mean if he keeps the bishop which of
course he wants to to have some kind of
play against my king then I take B 3 as
well so and then i blundered a piece I
mean this was kind of oh yes like yeah
that's War III I I was looking at this
idea but not in this particular moment
when I for just wins a piece just
incredibly embarrassing did you see it
when in a question of 95 or we were you
are nowhere blissfully unaware yeah yeah
yeah III saw it after I tried to oh wow
no a this was not a game to play with
that pressure on you yeah the first game
I I think was also not great but I can
understand it's very difficult to play
positions with a low time I mean I don't
think this was too egregious he was
winning but I it's really not easy to
keep control so I can understand
I'm missing missing the win here at and
I almost thought I'm winning it's like
he SH he's kind of like plane only moves
to to survive here
exactly oh and yeah the Berlin endgame
of course where he wondered
he played works yet and he I guess
blundered or catch one or something was
also kind of a one move I mean a game
which was a which was spoiled by one
move pretty much cuz it was kind of
interesting than I thought if he doesn't
play rook c8 he takes on e6 and brings
us a cute like rook g7 King F a dork c7
King g8 he gets counter play against
Viking so and it's probably completely
fine for him King G then work up theta
and I think it's I was gonna play where
would you want and trade everything to a
draw basically cuz I didn't want to
worry to to deal with his attack up to
rook a fate which could get quite
serious so yeah overall okay a day with
a lot of mistakes but we did play it saw
like we were playing simple positions
with the exception of one game we played
extremely complex positions well I'll
let you go Fabi as we have Wesley
waiting as well you ended up with a 50%
score in terms of the number of wins but
you find yourself trailing at this point
certainly a very different match than
you had in the semis what are your
feelings right at this moment well I
think that because of the scoring system
it very often turns into like a norm
again in a situation at the end like I'm
not sure a point deficit is actually
much different from 50% if we had let's
say drawn all the games today because it
will if it stays tight it will come down
to those last two games unless unless
they both end in draws like yesterday
the Nakamura situation was basically an
Armageddon he had to win with white and
usually if you have to win with white
it's a must-win where you go to a
tiebreaker but his situation was where
he would actually win the match outright
so it could it could very well come down
to one of those situations again you
know one of us has to has to basically
win Armageddon where we don't have
a time advantage when you start there
you go all right well thanks so much for
joining us get your rest good luck
tomorrow thank you thank you fabbi
indeed and I agree with Bobby I think
that there is we all think that it's
gonna come down to the last game and now
we have Wesley so leaving the match by
one point on the line hey Wesley great
job today
hi Jennifer how you got there Oh Murray
did you get 14 hours of sleep again
Lasley not very difficult but he said I
was very excited to play in the final
and it's not so EP when you're looking
forward to the game so tell us you you
must have heard everything Fabi just
said what was your feeling as the match
was progressing before this final game
today oh well actually I was very
disappointed not to win the first game
here the first game because I I checked
it later and then it was completely
winning but not so easy okay things
happen and then in the end I wasn't been
risking big of making was under attack
but here if I played this correct h5
night of 55:27 I think if I played be
527 if I played Queen f2 after 27
it's a bishop before I play Queen up to
here I think I cut him of all his
counter play then I play Knight c3
Knight d5 they're making suddenly very
safe and it should be easily winning
that looks but yeah I think a strong
yeah because making a flaw chief Queen
it not to coach but I allowed him too
much counter play your Bishop e4
definitely did allow him some counter
play here yeah I was actually fortunate
not to lose but here I'll have another
try after Queen h4 check probably King G
instead of P&G one we should be winning
in G then if play happens like in the
game let's say I I think Jennifer wanted
to play Queen takes f4 oh no this wasn't
Queen takes EE a check okay yeah
very white yeah it's not for Queen d8
all right so you're feeling then this
game I thought this game would be a bit
demoralizing because you thought you
were so winning and it seemed to last
with you throughout the match because
you weren't able to get your bearings in
the next four games even giving him a
full plankton and that blunder as well
rook c8 in the Berlin I thought you were
definitely gonna have some kind of
mindset like maybe you were getting it
done today
yeah exactly a good point after that I
had kind of a little bit snowball I lost
this Burlingame and but the thing is
actually it's not so easy anymore after
would be 7 I have the player Stacy fix
yeah and then I think Fabian also
mentioned it and then I have to fight
stubbornly for a draw
yep you pick through p7 so he will be 17
f8 57 and then he winds up on b7 and
it's not so easy to defend because the
Panthers flip but but yeah it should be
a draw but not so easy so how did you
get your mind right last game well
actually I think the turning point was
in the third game in the in the modern
Banani right the one you say I was
better
it took only four right there I was
better and then when I played row Katie
I suddenly realized here at night before
basically toes and what do you have for
well because I saved I save the game
like I
it's very important not to loose white
games in the match and I was fortunate
enough to to save the game because I was
really determined to hold this one
because if I lose this one then I would
have lost two in a row and I would be
black next game and so this was really a
turning point today when I when I say
this very important game but did I give
in to the rest of the games all right
did he give you cards what did you feel
a sigh of relief like okay now you can
you could maybe come back in the match
yeah exactly yeah because not losing a
white game is is huge and I will be down
to a point and I would have black so I
would probably lose the next one again
[Laughter]
but yeah like like it might match with
Magnus just a few days ago I oh I also
lost two games with white and that was a
huge blow which I could not recover from
and yeah the problem in this in this bit
time dr. Seuss I get very ambitious with
the white pieces and then I end up in
terrible positions I take the net state
yeah yeah that's a problem we'll get
ambitious with white and then you get
cute oh it need to be a fine line but
Wesley like if I could ask a question in
this game in the benoni which you
described as a turning point in a game
that you were determined to save did you
realize at any point during the game
that you had missed an actual winning
moment at this opportunity after Knight
takes d5 you very quickly played the
move h4 and you had missed this move
effort that it occurred to you after
that you may have missed an opportunity
no I did not occurred to me at all but
they have that for okay yep because he
mentioned that he did see it after he
played Knight d5 and he felt terrible he
did interesting because
like for other good move besides I think
it's a and then their Europe or not
party never know that things would get
worse
I will ask you there Wesley yesterday
you found yourself down after losing a
game 602 Nakamura that is not yesterday
but two days ago you find yourself down
to losing Game six now you find yourself
up after winning Game six the exact same
scenario what's your mindset going into
tomorrow yesterday I look you were down
against Naruto day one day one of the
semi-finals you were down because you
lost Game six and and he took that
clutch game and took a lead two to two
points in that clutch game and he was
ahead then you got your 13 or 14 hours
of sleep you came tonight and you blitz
them today you find yourself in that
situation that he was in you're up after
winning Game six
what's your thought in your strategy
going into tomorrow well it's very nice
to win that clutch game because I
haven't won any clutch game yes and yeah
and these yeah they they give a lot of
bonus with this clutch game and they're
also double the point please it's a
clutch game for actually everything that
matters in this in this tournament so
it's a big sigh of relief but yeah yeah
because either picker escaped in this
first question and then and then yeah
and then I couldn't win any after that
but in terms of the match it's we're
technically around even right now but
the last two games tomorrow will be huge
because they're worth six points and
does it matter
given the rollover potential that
tomorrow's games are gonna be worth
eight thousand dollars each
how does that affect the match
well yeah yeah it is actually
alpha I'm very pleased that we're having
this online tournament and thank you to
you guys for hosting this tournament
into st. Louis because in this times up
in this time of weird things happening
all over the world there are actually no
chess tournaments like like right now so
so it's really a big a big help that we
have this online chess tournament
because also or for us the top there we
kind of need a lot of practice in order
to maintain their strength and I haven't
played the tournament in five months so
I'm feeling a bit rusty right now but
certainly Wesley we know four for one
let's thank dr. Jeanne sing filled in
and Rex Sinquefield for their generosity
they wanted to make sure that you guys
kept that form and I didn't lose out on
the opportunities that you deserve and
everyone here at the club joy Bray and
Tony rich leads such a fantastic team as
you know and we're grateful to you for
being one of the great players in the
country and regale us with your talents
we look forward to seeing you tomorrow
Wesley get your rest and good luck good
luck Wesley
- oh sorry Jenn what were you saying I
was gonna just say that it's so much fun
when Wesley Cell was playing Wow because
he's he's just got this magic majestic
touch and he's always so switch cheerful
in the interviews just a really a
brilliant smile but I I think
I think both of these guys Wesley and
Fabi he goes in as a leader tomorrow but
as laviano pointed out who seems to
really big punching the numbers by the
way hey he's got him he's got in the
mind for this type of thing he's
calculated and he thinks that it's very
likely this final game it's gonna go
into an Armageddon sight situation where
somebody's gonna have more point than
the other person and it's gonna be all
about winning with white or sometimes
potentially when he was glad but let's
take a look at the schedule tomorrow
we've got four regular games and then we
got those troop up game which are worth
triple points so unless somebody gets
way ahead before game eleven and twelve
those are gonna be the money games quite
literally and that there's gonna be
eight at stake in them and potentially
even more if eleven game is gone but in
addition to that they're gonna decide
the match jazz and I think of it it's
gonna be game twelve that decides that
nobody's gonna be out of it until the
very last move I buy that I you're three
I agree table is gonna make it really
important all this there's only one way
you could have it if somebody's leading
after game ten and they win game eleven
then the match is over
that's sites that's gonna be a lot of
pressure on whoever's trailing at that
point because game 11 could decide it if
for example things stay the way they are
right now if Bobby doesn't want to see
Wesley win that game eleven because then
the match is over
without game twelve there's the play
though because it is eight grand on the
line for game 12 anyway so they
definitely want that that clutch bunny
as well but in terms of the match itself
those two games loom large in the match
it will not end before then I'd put C
actually game it can't end I don't think
now mathematically it can end before
gaming
full game 11 you know now then the half
points is there a magic number I don't
think they can get there no they can't
make it there's no way there's no way so
many no the clutch games 11 12 will
count
they'll be big-time games tomorrow very
exciting moment for this for this match
what a date tomorrow will bring loving
it I'm very excited we're gonna see you
all tomorrow then I'm looking forward to
the two Jen Maurice thank you so much it
was a great day thanks to all of our
viewers and we will see you tomorrow
same time same place as we determine the
winner of the very first clutch chess
showdown
[Music]